getting bigger but the video part is
getting to a larger percentage 3 2 1
gentlemen we're live here we go
Jordan Peterson Bret Weinstein how are
you guys doing very well thanks for
coming in to be here how excited to have
you in hey should be funny you're spiffy
you make us look very slubby what are
you doing what can I say man you know I
only brought a limited number of clothes
well good move you look great and good
to see you guys both of you and so whose
idea was that to do this first of all so
just uh I think it was I think it was
Brett's yeah I saw a tweet of Jordans
about or maybe it wasn't a tweet I did
see a YouTube clip that somebody tweeted
I don't know if it was you your
perspective on on Hitler and your
argument was that he was actually even
far worse than his reputation would lead
us to believe and it's funny it it
harkens back to my first evolutionary
project as an undergraduate I was
working with Bob Trevor's who's went the
leading evolutionary minds of the 20th
century he was I was lucky enough to
have him as an undergraduate advisor
pull this sucker right up to your face
because he's gonna turn sideways cause
we're looking at each other next to each
other yeah yeah okay so anyway I did a
project with Bob on analyzing the
Holocaust from an evolutionary
perspective I wanted to test the
question about whether you know at the
time it was it was commonplace for
people to say that Hitler was crazy and
there was something that bothered me
about that analysis I think there's
something actually dangerous that we
dismiss somebody like Hitler as crazy
before we understand actually what
they're up to so when I saw your your
video clip I thought it would be worth
having a discussion so that we could
figure out what perspective makes sense
that sounds like an awesome topic but
before we get to that I would really
like to know what's going on with you
because you're at the center of this
crazy controversy of Evergreen State
College you essentially left the area
you're suing the college now so where do
you stand now we have not yet filed suit
and in fact
I'll talk about what took place inside
the negotiation but we had our first
sit-down with the college yesterday and
this was a attempt to avert a suit but I
will say from where I sit as hard as
this is to believe it appears that the
college has learned nothing from this
episode and that it is doubling down on
the same foolish sets of beliefs and
assumptions that got it into trouble in
the first place so that that is not a
hopeful situation no and for anybody
that's not aware of what this whole
story is about you would either have to
go back to Bret's podcast that we did a
few months back or please just Google
Evergreen State University and Google
Bret and you will be blown away by the
incent it's social justice warrior gone
amuck the whole campus kids patrolling
the campus with baseball bats I mean the
whole thing is just completely bananas
the president of the university being
told by the children not to use his
hands when he's speaking because it's a
microaggression so he puts his hands
down the children start cheering and
laughing they don't realize they're
being played the whole thing is just
some crazy grand game by the children
and I'm calling them children I don't
give a [ __ ] how old they are to have
power over people I means essentially
what this is all boiled down to and you
really see it in that moment where they
tell him to put his hands down and he
does and they laugh and cheer and think
it's amazing well you know they're
educated to do that to some degree
because one of the tenants of the
post-modernism that they're being
spoon-fed is that there's no such
there's nothing but power that's the
only thing that mediates relationships
between people because there's no real
world everything's a social construct
and it's a landscape of conflict between
groups that's that's the postmodern
world and the only the only actual means
of expression is power that's what
that's why the post modernists make the
claim constantly that the patriarchy is
a corrupt institution because they look
at hierarchical organizations and
they're stratified obviously there's
people at the top and people at the
bottom the only reason that there are
people at the top is because they
dominate by power there's no there's no
philosophy of authority or competence
that's all gone and so and and if you're
cynical about that sort of thing and you
should be you might say that part of the
reason that the only thing that the post
modernists believe in his power is
because that helps them justify their
arbitrary use of it under any
circumstances whatsoever and I think
that's right
I think that's exactly what happened so
it's not surprising that that you see
this manifested in mob-like behavior of
the students it's right in accordance
with everything they're being taught so
well they're also being taught and this
sort of any means necessary
to to get over the establishment like
the establishment is this horrible
institution and they could justify
pretty much anything yeah this is what
like punch a Nazi who's a Nazi everybody
that doesn't agree with you
I mean it's essentially what's what's
being said ad nauseam in in social
justice warrior circles online in eec
I've seen punch of Nazi so many times I
mean but when it came down to
Charlottesville's there was very little
punching of Nazis you know the whole
thing was like it's all it's all very
insane we see real Nazis those are real
Nazis you know yeah go [ __ ] punch
them please
you know before we've also I think don't
even do that by the way right well I
think we've already figured out everyone
right from the right to the left
everyone's figured out that wherever the
Nazis went that was wrong
we all agreed on that we're not going
there anymore and so when someone pops
up and says well we should go there it's
like they're immediately identifiable
you can box them in and if you have any
sense like you know like many
conservatives did in the aftermath of
the Charlottesville they come out and
say well in case it needs to be said
again we're actually not allied with
those people yeah well that's one of
them that was the most disturbing thing
for many people about Donald Trump's
reaction to it that he didn't take a
hard stance against these white
supremacists showing up with tiki
torches walking to the street yelling
anti-semitic phrases or whatever I don't
know exactly what they're yelling I've
read a bunch of different things but the
whole thing was a is it a bomb in
ancient I mean it was a horrific thing
to watch and you know Donald Trump comes
out and says there was horrible behavior
on all sides yeah well I thought I
thought about that for a lot because I
got tangled up with that in a strange
way in Canada I was supposed
appear on a panel a panel discussing the
suppression of free speech on university
campuses which was then promptly
cancelled by the university that was
going to host it in the aftermath of
Charlottesville partly because one of
the panelists was going to be faith
Goldie who was the journalist that was
covering Charlottesville and got the
footage of the of the car and and the
damage but we we were targeted
immediately afterward with the Nazi
epithet and Ryerson cut shut down the
shut down the free speech panel so it's
coming up again and nobody does you were
targeted as Nazis yeah yeah yeah what
happened was this this this this this
person put up a Facebook page and used a
swastika with an O you know like a
circle with a line through it and said
no fascists no fascists at Ryerson
essentially but she used the swastika
and she got a bunch of people rallied
together to pressure the university
administration into counseling the event
which they promptly did and then they
had a celebration party the night of the
event and this is here something that
was really interesting so they got a
couple I think a couple of hundred
people out to the celebration at Ryerson
and they they were united under the
banner of the hammer and sickle and were
calling for revolution and what was so
interesting about that and I really mean
technically that it was interesting was
that the mainstream media said virtually
nothing about the fact that these let's
call them counter protesters I don't
know exactly how you'd term them had
come out under this murderous symbol and
that's made me think like I can't figure
out why the swastika is an immediate
identifier of a pathological personality
and the hammer and sickle isn't there's
actually a reason it isn't just
arbitrary and I think maybe it's
something like the Nazi is the guy who
knifes you in the alley and steals your
wallet and the communist is the
white-collar criminal who takes your
pension and you're actually more afraid
of the first person then the second
person because the damage they do is
more proximal and a meat and emotionally
recognizable but that's the second guy
who takes your pension for example he's
perhaps even more dangerous but there's
a there's a bloodiness about the Nazi
symbol and
immediate emotional impact that the
hammer and sickle just doesn't produce
and and some of that's because people
are badly educated historic events it is
pure ignorance I don't think it's just
ignorance no I think that the people
that are wearing those Che Guevara
t-shirts really understand the history
of Che Guevara or do you think he
represents this sexy South American
counter-protest character a guy who
stands up to the establishment as we
know it a guy was wearing a green beret
wearing a beret hiding in the jungle
fighting against the oppressive
dictatorship of America I mean that's
what that's what they're looking at when
they see what well the the fact that
historical ignorance plays a role in
this is absolutely certain and I think
the romanticization of people like Che
Guevara is exactly I think you nailed
that exactly but I do think there's a
deeper question here it's like I was
thinking in the aftermath of
Charlottesville many conservatives
immediately divorced themselves from the
Nazis ben shapiro was a good example
yeah and and it was very much
reminiscent of William F Buckley
divorcing himself from the John Birch
Society back in the 1960s the right-wing
seems it seems to be easier for the
right-wing to draw a line around the
Nazis and say no that's not us partly
because the right-wingers conservatives
are better at drawing boundaries but you
know let's say we wanted to draw a
boundary around the radical leftists
okay point to something well on the
right you say well you were a swastika
yeah you're out of the club man right on
the left well you believe what's the
smoking pistol you believe in equity
it's like that's that's a smoking pistol
as far as I'm concerned but it doesn't
have the same emotional punch as you
wore a swastika to the protest yeah you
believe in equity and you refuse to
define it that would be right right but
that's such a wait there's no punch in
that it's like well I'm not going to
associate with you because you believe
in equity it's like it's too complicated
hmm that's right
um I do want to back us up here though
because the I think we underrate the
danger of and I think Nazis are a red
herring there is something that actually
does threaten to reemerge and
Charlottesville is a version of it but I
think because we have a cartoon
understanding of what that protest was
actually about and how many people are
actually involved we don't really see
why this is a dangerous and
just issue and I think the answer is an
evolutionary one that hasn't been
spelled out and because it hasn't been
spelled out it's very hard to point to
I'd like to keep interrupting you but
just get this right up to your face it
sounds good to us but the people
listening online or is that better yeah
just when you turn to him just turn the
thing with you okay yeah just get it you
always keep it a fist from your face
that's the best uh sorry that's all
right so explain what you mean by this
so my point would be that what took
place in Germany in the 30s was a
particularly particularly visible well
documented example of a pattern that is
much more common in human history
and because this pattern emerges as a
result of certain features of the way
evolution functions in the context of
humans it is actually always a danger
that it will re-emerge and knowing what
to do about it is not so simple until
you've seen why it occurs and what it
means what I what I've been saying in
lectures I've given on this is that
tyranny is the end game of prosperity
and so there is a pattern in which you
will go through a period of prosperous
Ness in which it appears that that thing
is defeated once and for all there's no
reason for people to be going after each
other in this particular way and then at
the point that that pattern Peters out
it reimagined people don't expect it it
flies under a different flag or
something like that
and so I do think that looking at the
tiny number of people who were doing
what they were doing in Charlottesville
and saying well that's we all agree that
this is wrong misses the fact that
actually I think Trump is doing it
cynically but Trump was riding a wave
that there are there are ideas which are
not permissible from the environments in
which we all grew up that are going to
become permissible again if we are not
careful to recognize that that's that's
the nature of history I think I think
it's highly probable that that's going
to occur I mean part of the reason that
I landed in the political hot water that
I landed in last year was because
was increasingly aware that this process
of polarization was going to take place
and that the continual in my estimation
anyways the continual clawing of new
ground underneath a radical leftist
rubric especially in the universities is
is starting to produce an
extraordinarily dangerous counter
position and that was manifest at least
to some degree in charlottesville and so
I think you're right is that well I you
don't want to be complacent say well we
know who the Nazis are and we're not
going there and so the problem is solved
the problem isn't solved there's all
sorts of weird activity in the non
radical left space like on the other
side of the radical left whatever that
is and right now what it is is not
obvious you know it's it's the alt lab
all right that's part of it it's the
kickass danny's it's this peppy thing
it's it's some of its comedy some of its
satire some of its serious some of its
the inversion of identity politics which
is very dangerous and it's maybe the
most dangerous thing about
charlottesville is that there's
something there's something
extraordinarily dangerous about having
people revert to identification with
their racial identity it's really not a
good thing
well there's the reversion to their
racial identity there's basically an
outbreak of tribalism which explains
what's going on on the far right what's
going on on the left is a bit of a new
twist what you have is a coalition of
different tribal identities that aren't
large enough to marshal a force on their
own and so they're united and together
they are a formidable force but what's
going to happen is that something that's
an unstable
entity at the point that that force
gains power it's going to come apart
internal dynamics rip it up so it's not
actually a it's not capable of
restraining the version that recurs on
the right the version that does manifest
as as white nationalism that version is
stable because it does represent an
actual population that has an
evolutionary basis for remaining
cohesive and I should point out there is
a danger when you hear an evolutionary
biologist talk about evolutionary
patterns peep
often infer that if an evolutionary
biologist is saying that something is a
pattern that has evolved that that's
some kind of a defense and it is
absolutely not we call this the
naturalistic fallacy so evolution is an
absolutely amoral process it has
produced the most marvelous features of
human beings and the worst features and
we are in some sense obligated to pick
and choose which features to honor and
and promote and which ones to tamp down
something can have something can have
evolved as a virtue in some
circumstances and still be of the type
that if magnified beyond its proper
limits becomes pathological so let me
tell you something I learned about
Hitler which really I haven't recovered
from my shock from this so we've been
looking at the relationship between
political belief and personality okay
and your political belief is strongly
determined by your temperament so
liberal left types are high and trade
openness that's creativity and low in
conscientiousness but you can fragment
conscientiousness up into
industriousness and orderliness and the
real predictor for conservatism is an
orderliness not industriousness and you
might think well that's no surprise
right wingers are more orderly hence
Hitler's call for order let's say but
it's one thing to to posit that and
another thing to measure it and now it's
measurable and it appears that
orderliness is associated with
sensitivity to disgust and this is
actually a really big deal it's a really
big deal so there's a paper that was
published in PLoS ONE about three years
ago looking at the relationship between
the prevalence of infectious diseases
and authoritarian political attitudes
and they did a country-by-country and
then within countries by state or
province and the correlation between the
prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian / right-wing political
beliefs at the local individual level
was 0.6 and so I want to take this apart
a little bit okay so the idea is that
this is part of what you might describe
as the extended behavioral immune system
and one of the problems with the
interactions between groups of human
beings in our evolutionary past was well
exactly what happened to the Native
Americans is you know they came out and
shook hands with the Spanish
conquistadors and then within a couple
of generations 90% of them were dead of
smallpox and measles and mumps and so
it's been a truism in our
they passed that if you meet a group of
isolated if you're a group of isolated
humans and you meet another group of
isolated humans and you trade pathogens
there's a real possibility that you and
everyone you know are going to be dead
in no time flat
and so we have a discussed mechanism
that that produces this implicit let's
call it racial racial and ethnic bias
that is part and parcel of the human
cognitive landscape but the problem with
that is that it's rooted in a discussed
mechanism that actually serve as a
protective function now when I was
sorting this out I was reading Hitler's
Table Talk and Hitler's Table Talk is a
very interesting book it's a book of his
spontaneous mealtime utterances from
1939 to 1940 - and I went through with
this new knowledge because people think
of conservatives as a like or fascists
as afraid of those who are different
they're not afraid they're disgusted and
that's not the same thing because you
burn things you're disgusted by and so
it was terrifying to me to read it
because then I also thought oh well
disgust sensitivity is associated with
orderliness and you need order in a
society in order to maintain it and the
Germans are very orderly and that was
actually a canonical part of their
civilization and part of actually what
makes them great and powerful and that
just had to tilt a little farther than
necessary and all of a sudden everything
needed to be get cleaned and you know
Hitler talked about cleanliness all the
time and he actually meant that and so
this thing that's emerging you know you
talked about its biological basis its
evolutionary basis it is it's part of
this deeply rooted discussed system that
protects us from dangerous pathogens
that can manifest itself and does
manifest itself in the political realm
it's not good so he I don't know exactly
how to tease this apart but I agree with
your point about there's an actual
danger when populations meet like a
literal pathogen danger and that that is
liable to have produced a certain
instinctive fear of the other which
doesn't have to be limited to that one
thing but that's enough to generate a
selective force that would cause a
certain reluctance to meet but I want I
want to point out that at least in the
West and probably universally human
beings when they go to war tend to
dehumanize the other population
and you know so of course calling the
the other population subhuman Vermin
whatever it is that that human beings do
and my concern is that we are doing
exactly this with the Nazis or de facto
Nazis who are showing up on on our
screens at this point that what we are
doing is we are comforting ourselves by
saying well that's a small outbreak of
something that makes these people
subhuman and justifies punching them or
whatever and I'm you know I'm not
squeamish about there being a right to
violence when somebody is threatening a
way of life so it's not that but my
concern is that if you take the pathogen
model and you imagine that all those
folks who showed up in charlottesville
that that is a contagion and it needs to
be isolated then you will have the sense
that as long as you do that it's not
going to show up somewhere else whereas
what's I think the the actual hazard is
that that's actually a latent program
that has served populations in past
circumstances it's indefensible but it
has served populations and the
populations that we come from have it
therefore on reserve and when certain
characteristics show up in the
environment that program can emerge and
so my concern is that that's where we
are in right it can't be isolated as a
phenomena that's associated with the
other right in one of the things I've
done for decades is teach my students a
variant of that which is something like
because we I try to walk them through
understanding psychological
understanding of what happened in Nazi
Germany and in the more intense
situations like in places like in
Auschwitz so the question might be well
if you were in Germany than the 1930s
could you be a constant concentration
camp guard and the gut reaction to that
is no those people are unlike me and
that's the wrong response the right
response is those people were human and
I'm also human and so that means that
the Nazi is us that's what it means and
so that and who the hell wants to think
that and no one will think that and I
have thought that through because I
thought through for a variety of reasons
what the limits of my potential behavior
are and the limits of my potential and
maybe I'm more pathological than the
average person it's certainly possible
but I understand that the limits of my
potential behavior are
beyond the bounds of what people would
normally consider civilized and I think
that's characteristic of human beings in
general well so I mean you know looking
oh go ahead no I was gonna say I think
this is one of the things that really
highlights the importance of having
uncensored discussions because we've
we've already hit on so many hot topics
to the point where you have to like
really clarify your position and and
when you're talking about this sort of
latent program in in in human beings and
the necessity for it at one point in
time like all these things are very
taboo to discuss today and this is a
giant issue because what you guys are
doing is talking about things
objectively reasonably logically and and
clearly but when you get to these sort
of hysterical subjects that's that's
sort of forbidden today and there's a
giant issue with that because when you
have forbidden discussions you energize
those topics and the the topics grow in
the absence of discussion in the absence
of being picked apart and analyzing them
for what their core components are and
what are we talking about it from an
evolutionary perspective this is very
very important because these patterns
are really do see that and I think with
any one of us given the wrong
neighberhood the wrong parents the wrong
life we might have been one of those
[ __ ] with the tiki torches in
charlotte i mean it's where human beings
like you said i think that is absolutely
critical to discuss well and it's also
there's there's another thing going on
right now i've been trying to
characterize the state of the
sociological and psychological landscape
that we all inhabit right now and i
think we're in a position of radical
instability and things in the future
could be way better than they are right
now radically and they could be way
worse than they are and small decisions
are going small to small decisions that
people make are going to have outsized
effects well they make them like look at
what happened with this guy in
Charlottesville you know this was I mean
I know he was surrounded by a coterie of
deplorable --zz let's say but it was one
guy who decided to do something
murderous and that shifted the whole
political landscape and and and so what
I see happening right now is the
we're surrounded by these interactions
between people that are positive
feedback loops you know and a positive
feedback loop occurs when if you do
something then it makes whatever caused
that occur even in a greater way and the
polarization is like that so I say
something left like and you say
something right like and that annoys me
so I get more left and it annoys you and
you get more right and all of a sudden
were at each other's throats and that's
happening everywhere right it's very
unstable and what what's to be hoped for
is that we can pull back from that and
discuss it we can say look you know
under a circumstance a I could have been
a communist Inquisitor or Nazi prison
guard I need to know that and then I
need to know what were the situations
that made that likely and then I need to
know how should I conduct myself so
that's less possible and the only way we
can figure that out is to have the kind
of conversations that we're having right
now it's like and this isn't them I've
been taken to task by some of my friends
for example for using the social justice
warrior terminology because they've said
to me well you know you're you're you're
participating in this process of
demonization and and polarization and I
think well yeah I can understand that
although I'm also like radically
concerned about the fact that the
universities for example are completely
taken over by radical Marxists
essentially and that they're driving
this polarization and it isn't obvious
to me how to have a discussion about
that without participating in the
process of polarization it's something
I've been trying to figure out for the
whole last year you know and I've made
I've been emphasizing the role of
personal responsibility instead of
ideological identification right get it
into your head that you have the
capacity for great evil and stop
targeting stop assuming that that's
something that's manifesting itself only
in the people that you disagree with
politically take responsibility for that
and try to put your life together I
don't see an alternative to that but
it's been very difficult to to to avoid
to do that and simultaneously to avoid
becoming a participant in this process
of polarization and it's a very
dangerous process it's what destabilized
Germany in the 1920s and 30s right it
was this ping-ponging back and forth
between the radical left and the radical
right and your point bread that the
radical right actually is more powerful
once they get organized is a really good
one
because there's no fractionation it's
more stable you bet and they have all
the guns that's another thing to think
about certainly in this country the
right is much better armed and that's
very frightening
that's a tariff terrifying thought that
you know I mean we've we've heard this
many times recently about the Trump
administration about if he's impeached
that there will be some sort of a civil
war
I believe Roger stone said that like
this thought is so terrifying that we
literally cannot do anything to stop
some sort of physical confrontation with
weapons if we disagree ideologically
that it's going to happen well first of
all there's a lot we can do and sure
fact you know one of the other things
about about the evolutionary toolkit is
that I believe we have exactly the tools
for navigating this puzzle they're built
into us also in addition to this latent
program but we are now in a very
dangerous situation because for example
if Google and other of these online
goliaths start deploying algorithms that
decide what we get to talk about and see
then we cannot use the very tools that
are necessary in order to escape and
avoid something like civil war which
frankly communication and debate
analyzing all the components of this
issue completely objectively yeah I'm
taking the risks that are necessary with
that and some of the risks are that if
we have free and open communication that
some percentage of that communication is
going to be reprehensible and deplorable
but yes but that but that the
consequences of suppressing that are so
much more dangerous than the
consequences of allowing it that they're
not in the same universe yes we empower
us those terrible ideas by making them
I mean electronically taboo yeah and
then point is they're going to fester
whereas if we just if we discussed them
we can defuse the ones that are terrible
we can spot the opportunities that we
don't know we have and we can we can
move forward rather than descend into
civil war which frankly looks more this
issue with with Google and YouTube let's
say and these are the gigantic internet
companies you know it isn't a matter of
if they're going to produce autumn
BOTS that do pre perceptual censorship
they are doing that well 16 wet sad
explained well he tweeted the other day
that and I knew this was in the workings
because I've been looking at what
YouTube and Google are planning with
regards to their artificial intelligence
censors let's say you know they want to
get to the point where the the the
appalling video is not even put up so
what happened I hope I've got this
exactly right but God was in the process
you upload a video and then you publish
it and so once you upload it YouTube has
access to it and they have access to its
content and they informed him that it
would be d monetized before he published
it is right here we put it up on the
board there you go YouTube thinks that
my pointing to astounding hypocrisy is
to triggering there is nothing
objectionable object objectionable in my
clip unbelievable yeah and that one was
a manual review so I'm wrong about that
although how in the world they decided
that they were going to manually review
God's video is also I mean how many
videos are going up on YouTube what the
hell why are they manually reviewing his
and I mean God said is not a radical
right now that's the thing I mean he's
an evolutionary biologist and that makes
him a radical now it does because he's a
bunch of questioning what's happening
and by questioning what's happening you
instantaneously get lumped into this
right-wing hate group well he's also
making the claim that human beings have
an intrinsic nature and so now there's a
new buzz phrase that goes along with
that and so that's that you're a
biological essentialist
and you see so if you're a radical
postmodern neo-marxist your theory is
human beings can be anything that I want
to make them into it's a core doctrine
of the theory and it's part of what
makes it intensely totalitarian because
then human beings are just putty for the
molding and that's part of the the
motivation will drive for claiming the
radical constructionist claim there's no
biological essence well why do you make
that claim well because we want to free
people from prejudice and tyranny it's
like no that's not why you make that
claim you make that claim because you
want to justify your claim that there's
absolutely nothing wrong with making
over humanity in the in an image of your
ideology and and and that's that would
that that was a well documented
intellectual argument that that that
wove through what happened in communist
Russia for example because the claim
they're explicitly was you wipe out the
past there's no real biological identity
you can mold the human of the future in
the image of your perfectionistic
ideology and and the the Russians
actually sidelined themselves
effectively with respect to evolutionary
theory that basically they were so
backward on a biological front that as
they were deploying this this very
broken ideological toolkit they were
wrecking their ability to think about
about how biology works and so what
you're pointing to you about
evolutionary biologists it's not just
that we question the content of
evolutionary biology is absolutely the
opposite of politically correct yes yes
because nobody tells the biota what's
right and what's wrong the biota does
what it does and those of us who look at
it and attempt to understand what those
patterns are can't help but be deeply
politically incorrect almost all the
time and so the idea that the truth of
biology is actually going to become
unexpressable and we're gonna move ahead
we're just gonna we're gonna we're gonna
sideline it so that we can move ahead
with this ideological stuff I mean that
is ecology is racist and sexist you well
if I might biology and we're gonna have
to go back here in order to collect a
tool but biology does create entities
that have the potential for racism in
them in our genomes we carry the
potential for racism for Darwinian
reasons sexism is a little different
right it is so I'm about to become very
politically incorrect oh yeah I know oh
it is not possible for male genes to
gang up on female genes because all of
our genes spend half their time in male
bodies and half their time in female
bodies which does not mean that
civilization is fair with respect to sex
and gender
it does mean that there's no biological
basis for the evolution of a patriarchal
force that subordinates women because
whatever the patriarchy does those who
are part of the patriarchy become female
in the next iteration and they suffer
the consequences of it this is not the
case with race unfortunately this is not
a good thing but it is a true thing in a
Darwinian sense one population can gang
up on another population and it has
happened again and again it explains all
of the worst chapters in human history
and so in some sense what I'm getting at
is that you want to understand that
process and once you understand what
your genes are actually up to and you
understand that your genes their
objectives in the universe are not
defensible what your genes want cannot
be defended in in rational terms then we
become free to do something else
to recognize that our genes are up to
things that we don't have any reason to
honor and we can we can basically take
them out of the control position but if
we imagine that what our genes are up to
must be all right and therefore it can't
include anything like racism then we're
just stuck then we don't have the tools
to to diffuse racism so one of the
things that happened when I made my
video so a year ago complaining about
Bill c16 in Canada and that was the one
that instantiated transgender rights one
of the things I was pointing to right
like my comments have nothing to do with
transgender rights but one of the things
I was pointing to that was that Canada
had built into the law a social
constructionist version of human
identity and that's actually the case so
for example now in Canada here's a
proposition which now has the force of
law there is no causal connection
between biological sex gender identity
gender expression and sexual proclivity
technically it's illegal to make a claim
that those things are causally linked
and the the causal link claim is a
biological claim and not only is it a
biological claim it's a factual claim
those four levels are so tightly linked
causally that there's hardly any
exceptions there are exceptions so
because every almost everyone who's
biological sex ismail considers
themselves male manifests themselves as
male and his heterosexual so they're
linked and the reason they're linked is
while there's biological and cultural
reasons but it's now in Canada the
proposition that they're independent is
now law and I was pointing that saying
we don't want to do that you don't
understand you've built social
constructionism into the law that means
that now it's illegal to be a biologist
well then everybody said oh no no no
that's not happening it's like don't kid
yourself
when you put things in the law things
happen and we were accused not only of
being Nazis and that was part of the
reason that the this this talk was shut
down but also of being biological
essentialists and biological
essentialism is the new buzzword for for
nazi essentially so i have to go please
do I want I want to correct you it's not
that it's illegal to be a biologist it's
just illegal to be any good at it is
there is there concern that putting
biology as fact may it will get in the
way of civilization because we're
supposed to be moving past all of these
issues we're supposed to be moving past
these things as we evolve we're supposed
to be looking people as being free to
choose whatever gender they like free to
choose whatever sexual orientation they
like free to express themselves in any
way and that by defining them by purely
biological terms we're essentially
relying on the meat wagon to lead us
through civilization rather than the
mind that's great that you did a very
good job of outlining the credible case
against biological essentialism and
because it can deteriorate into
something like eugenics there's a real
danger like a political danger on the
side of a biological determinant is a
danger in denying it as well because
then we can't use our rational minds to
truly mitigate whatever issues that we
would have with our biological urges and
that that's the irony of this yes
actually there is no there is an
argument to be made that we need freedom
from our biology yes and we have the
to do it most creatures wouldn't but the
human beings are constructed we
absolutely have the ability to be
rational about these things and decide
which things we want to bring into the
future but we can't do it if we don't
discuss these things in Reister well a
subset of males are are biologically
hyper aggressive you can identify them
at 2 years of age and they're the kids
if you put a bunch of 2 euros together
there's a small subset they're almost
all males about 5% of males who will
kick hit bite and steal ok so that's
their biological programming let's say
but the vast majority of them are
socialized by the time they're four
years old so that they're amazed yeah
sure absolutely
I mean it is yeah absolutely yeah and
the thing about about boys like that is
that if you socialize them properly it's
quite a bit of work because they're very
calm about it my son was like that and
if you socialize them properly then they
can become unbelievably useful their
courageous their forthright their their
you know they're they're they're not
going to back down from a challenge
there's all sorts of massive utility in
that and that's this proper interplay
between the biological circuitry and the
socialization but you know and with
James de Maura's memo you know he was
he's been accused of taking a biological
essentialist route which is not true one
of the things James said is look there's
credible evidence that there are
biologically mediated differences
between men and women at the level of
temperament and interest that are
actually large and profound and I would
say the science on that is sufficiently
settled so that someone can come out and
say that's scientifically credible now
that doesn't mean it's right because the
scientists could be wrong but what you
can't say is that what James d'amour
said was scientifically uninformed it
was scientifically informed but he also
said look let's make the assumption I'm
paraphrasing slightly but let's make the
assumption that we want to as a society
we want to extract maximum useful
economic value from talented people so
one of the things we want to do is if
some of those people are women and some
of them are men we want to understand
the actual differences between women and
men so that we can set up the workplace
so that both women and men can
contribute to the maximum economically
so that they can benefit as individuals
and every
can benefit socially so you can use the
biological so I mean for example one of
the thing here's here's a biological
problem on average women are more
agreeable than men and I think that's
because agreeable people are they're
self-sacrificing and I think as a woman
you need to be wired to be
self-sacrificing or you won't be able to
tolerate taking care of infants that's
my sense of it okay now there's some
problems with that it's like let's say
that a huge part of female wiring is is
tilted in the direction of the necessity
of self-sacrifice for infant care okay
that doesn't equip women very well for
dealing with with aggressive met because
of aggressive men and infants are not
the same creatures so women play a pay a
price being optimized to some degree for
infant care they pay a price that
they're less what would you call
prepared that's one way of thinking
about it indeed with dealing with hyper
aggressive and competitive men well one
of the consequences of that is that
agreeable people don't make as much
money and the reason for that is to make
money you actually have to be
disagreeable because you have to go to
your boss and say give me some bloody
money or something you don't like will
happen to you you have to I'll leave you
have to be able to fight for an idea -
yeah but so there's something that this
is a perfect test case so biologically
speaking there's a very good reason for
certain kinds of wisdom to be biased in
the direction of manifesting in females
females because they have the capacity
to have fewer offspring in a lifetime
than males are obligated as you say to
to care in a particular way and the fact
that care in human beings take so many
years has resulted in menopause emerging
and menopause essentially when a woman
is done producing new offspring her
interests in her evolutionary interest
which in this case I think are honorable
becomes synonymous with the lineage the
population because her offspring will
either do well or do poorly based on the
population that they're in so women have
a kind of farsightedness about lineage
and I don't think it has anything to do
with human women actually this is a
trait that we can see in females of
other species
so it's an ancient thing whereas males
are high variance that is to say a male
can have many offspring in a lifetime
many males have no offspring in a
lifetime and that high variance means
that to the extent that there's wisdom
that surrounds risk-taking that has
traveled historically along the male
path now in modern times there's no
reason that we can't look at these two
kinds of wisdom and democratize them
both right the fact is there's no reason
if you're born female that you can't
tune into what has historically been
male biased wisdom and take advantage of
that and we should be encouraging this
there's no reason that people have to
continue with problem is is that we
can't actually have a reasonable
discussion about it because you know the
discussion is often forestalled by the
claim that while men and women are
exactly the same it's like it's that's
not a helpful discussion and you know
with the agreeableness issue I don't
know exactly what should be done about
that but one of the consequences of it
is is that there's many reasons why why
the pay there's pay differential between
men and women and the issue itself is
very complex but we do know that
agreeable people overall make less money
in the same positions and it's because
they don't negotiate on their own behalf
very well now it's conceivable that you
could have an intelligent public policy
or corporate policy discussion about
what to do about that like maybe maybe
the rule is something like you review
male salaries once a year and female
salaries every eight months or something
like that you know and I'm not saying
that's a good idea I'm not saying that
I'm saying that if you if you take the
facts on the ground into account there
are ways that you might be able to use
them so that you could and I'm not going
to say level the playing field because I
think that's an appalling phrase but
maximize the possibility of economic
contribution across the genders which is
obviously in everyone's best interest
but we're not gonna do that when when
someone like James d'amour comes out and
he's no scientist you know well he has
some scientific training but that wasn't
his primary field of expertise he came
out and did a pretty credible job of
summarizing the literature he did it
because he had been subject to mandatory
diversity training and was asked to
produce a response he didn't do it so it
would go viral within the company and
become public and because he expressed
his opinion let's say imperfectly
he got fired it's like that's not good
man that's not that's not a good pathway
well it also wasn't good that his stuff
was being republished without citations
people were we're publishing it without
the scientific papers that were sort of
affirming what some of the things that
he was saying I couldn't make heads or
tails of it until I saw his original
version yeah and that goes back to the
the point I was making earlier about
this being this is an unstable time
where people's individual ethical
choices in some circumstances will have
effects far beyond the local it's like
those journalists who jumped on the
story did it either badly you know
because they were incompetent or they
did it maliciously right and that and
and so now we could say let's say things
go really badly in the next year well
then each of those journalists might be
able to sit at home and say hey I played
a causal role in bringing about this
state of murderous collapse because of
my little ethical my ethical lapse when
I was covering the James d'amore memo
you know because of my own laziness and
ideological rigidity I was willing to
play fast and loose with the truth and
now I've played a major causal role and
you know pushing everything towards a
state of chaos it's like people have
better be on their toes because we're in
a situation that's radically unstable
and so it's time it's it's a really good
time for everybody to be very careful
about what they write and say and about
their motives for for tarring and
feathering the opposition that's another
way of another thing that we have to be
very careful about it's just very
bizarre how quick people are to call
someone a racist today I mean I've never
seen anything like it in all my years
it's it's a strange time you know I got
into it yesterday just I got bored and I
started trolling with Pepe the Frog I
started putting up the Frog like with
rainbows saying this seems like a frog
that's really into gay rights like
here's a frog that holding a lemon with
a tart face like this is a frog that ate
a lemon and he's reacting to it like how
is this all racist like how is this like
anyone it's not like all these people
that are creating this frog are
coordinating anyone can make a meme with
the Frog and like a lot of the original
feels good man cart
that the guy created they those are
applicable to their silly a lot of them
are really silly well I think a lot of
it was an intentional troll yes so I
read a story about kekaa Stan you know I
was looking into it trying to figure out
if it was really you know the menace to
humanity that everybody claims it is and
the story was preposterous it was a you
know it's a magical place where we're
anti-semites and Jews and atheists and
religious people live in harmony which
is like that's hard to even parse it's
designed to cause your mind to throw an
error yeah well that is what though so I
I think this is an excellent thing to
talk about because I've been because
I've been let's say identified under
many circumstances now with the all
right I've been doing every bit of
investigation I can into its many
manifestations it's a very confusing
place it's certainly not an organized
place and exactly what it is is by no
means obvious and the cast an issue is a
good case in point because mostly that's
that's like a satirical realm where
where where I don't know what it is it's
late so its defensive humor in some
sense let me give you an example I gave
my father a kick-ass Danny Flagg about
three weeks ago and three weeks ago and
do that well because he's been following
what's happening to me online you know
and well and a lot and I got associated
with the frog in in a major way and it's
a crazy story I won't go into it but I
wore a frog hat on one of my videos that
an Indian Carver a Native American
Carver had given me and he had told me
that the Frog was in their culture a
harbinger of environmental instability
because if the waters polluted at all
the frogs died first so the Frog is the
the Frog is the creature in their
mythology that warns the society that
things are out of kilter
it's the canary in the coal the canary
in the coal mine so I wore this Frog hat
and I made this video about things being
unstable and I had been identified with
Kermit because my voice sort of sounds
like Kermit the Frog and it actually
does so I've been making jokes about
that and so then I made this video with
this frog hat and the frog that my
Carver friend made actually had red lips
and then I made the video and as soon as
I posted it people said that's Pepe and
I just about fainted literally because
it never occurred to me that that was a
connection
so anyways I've been tangled in with
this frog thing in this most absolutely
insane and surreal manner but I've been
so and that got me into the cast
anything and a lot of the people that
I'm trying to address online are young
men who are pushed I would say in a
right-leaning direction by the movement
of the radical left alienating and then
they're thinking well I'm certainly not
that right well then what am I
well maybe I'm the opposite of that well
is the opposite of the radical left the
alt-right or is there a better opposite
is there a different opposite that
people could flee to and that's what
well partly that's what I'm trying to
figure out but what does it have to be
opposite couldn't just be different well
that's the opposition is a real issue
with people right like what you were
talking about before when people just
ramped up their positions and get more
ideologically based and they're doing it
as a reaction to the other side instead
of just being who they are instead of
having some sort of a personal
sovereignty they are literally reacting
to the opposite side and changing who
they yes okay so what I've been trying
to do with my videos and and and and I
think this is part of the reason that
they've become so popular I'm in fact
I'm certain of it is that I've been
trying to agitate for the adoption of
that personal responsibility as an
alternative to political ideology it's
like get your act together have a vision
straighten out your life say what you
think you know stay away from the
ideological idiocy xand simplicity and
oversimplifications and try to put
yourself together because I think that I
do believe at the most fundamental level
and I think this is the remarkable
realization of Western civilization is
that the well-developed individual is
the antidote to the tyranny of society
and biology I think that's our great
discovery in the West it's not like
other cultures haven't had that idea in
nascent form but it's been hyper
developed in the West and I think it's
right and so we abandon that that that
pathway of divine individuality and
revert to ideological identification of
race or sex we're going to tear each
other to apart and I think part of the
reason we're motivated to do that show
is because many people don't want to
bear the responsibility of developing
themselves as individual
so they'll they'll shuffle off the
responsibility and if that means that
you know we're dancing in the streets
because everything's on fire that'll be
just fine and that's another thing
that's adding to the terrible danger
that we're in right now so I think
you're right and I think that personal
auditing program that you you're a part
of is gigantic and people look at it as
being separate from all these issues
that we're dealing with culturally but I
don't think it is I think you're
absolutely right and I think that there
is a real lack of struggle and
understanding of struggle with a lot of
people today not stress acerra ly
struggle financially but I mean like um
physical struggle spiritual struggle
understanding that you have to overcome
difficult issues to really understand
the true potential of your mind and your
body you have to not only overcome them
but you have to seek them out
voluntarily and-and-and what would you
say exalt in the fact that they exist
right yes and that's part of burying the
burden of being it's like being is a
tragic State human being is a tragic
state so you can shrink from that but if
you shrink from that the suffering
increases and intensifies and you become
resentful and malevolent yes
the alternative is to move forward
courageously that's the dragon motif
right that's the hero myth essentially
and that is the pathway forward as far
as I'm concerned well I think it also
has implications you know you're talking
about it at the level of what is best
for the individual but we also have a
problem which is that these collectivist
movements whether they are you know
white nationalists on the right or
social justice warriors on the left they
cannot see forward and what is missing
is that actually the mechanism that
allows us to discover new ways involves
individuals who are capable of thinking
independently and if you have multiple
individuals who think independently
about related matters then they can pool
that stuff but if what we do is we force
everybody to sign up for the same things
that we all agree are true there's no
way of discovering what we don't yet
know because every great idea starts
with a minority of one so we have to
have the freedom to be the only person
who believes something and then to
compel others that it's some
we're in the right neighborhood and for
others to pick up that mantle and so by
said board meeting that's exactly why I
you know I mean free speech has become
an India logical issue and increasingly
identified with but with the right and
which is horrible it's horrifying
but the the right justification for free
speech is what you just laid out which
is that in order for like the collective
is is a group of what's already known by
definition we inhabit the collective and
that's what's already known what we
could agree on but the problem with that
is that what we can agree on what's
already known isn't sufficient means we
still have problems so people have to be
out at the fringes on the border between
chaos and order where they discover new
things and communicate it back to the
collective free speech does that that's
the mechanism this is this is also a
deep evolutionary truth which is that
all of the innovations that allow
whether we're talking about one creature
learning to do some new trick that gives
rise to a bunch of species that do the
same trick or whether we're talking
about populations discovering a new way
to live on earth all of these things
proceed from the fringe right the people
at the Center for whom things are
working best aren't going to be the ones
to innovate the new way it's people for
whom things are not quite working that
are going to innovate new ways and that
that's also true for a population of
frogs or Birds or plants or whatever the
ones that are not well situated are the
ones where an experiment can pay off yes
why hands icing cake psychologist wrote
a good book called genius and he was
interested in what predicted high levels
of creative success and some of its what
you'd expect IQ is one of them and
creative temperament is another but
losing a parent before the age of 10 was
a nice predictor and you know people
think about creativity as if it's all
sweetness and light it's like no bloody
way man if you're gonna be creative it's
because you're tormented by a problem
right and so if you're not in a position
to be tormented by a problem you're not
gonna put in the time and effort and
take the risk necessarily necessary to
be creative so but you know I'm I've
been trying to understand the
evolutionary landscape out of which our
most fundamental religious convictions
emerge and the idea that it is by
definition the individual that innovates
and that by definition therefore it's
the individual that's the savior of the
collec
I mean it's hard to it's hard to imagine
how you could find a biological
Restatement of an essential Christian
presupposition that was more mapped one
to one than that now you could say well
that's not unique to Christianity I see
the same thing in the Judea in the
Jewish antithesis between the prophetic
tradition the prophet and the tradition
because the Prophet is always the lone
voice right that comes out it happens
over and over in the Old Testament a
lone voice comes out and challenges the
king and says look you know you're
you're a blind tyrant and nature is
moving away from us and preparing her
revenge and you better watch the hell
out because you're violating the
intrinsic moral norms and you're gonna
pay for it that happens over and over
and maybe there are 50 of them and the
one that gets recorded is the one that
happened to be closest to right because
that's the population that gets through
the bottleneck and so you know what we
have is sort of evolution authoring
these texts in a way yes well that's
that's not to claim that I'm very what
would you call that that's something I
believe to be fundamentally true and I
mean I've started I started see because
I'm interested in this idea of
strengthening the individually that's
and when I when I wrote my first book
maps of meaning it was about ideological
conflict and it was about whether or not
there was any alternative to ideological
conflict because you could make a case
that there isn't there's right and
there's left and there's a war right but
there is a third way and I think that is
the way of the heroic individual and I
mean that technically and that that
involves the development of individual
characters so that you can say what it
is that you think that you can
articulate your experience properly and
that you can bring what it is that's
unique to you into the collective
landscape and that's what updates the
collective landscape it's absolutely
vital and so I started doing these
biblical lectures I have done 12 of them
now walking through Genesis and what I'm
trying to do because I believe that the
Bible is the documentation of the
emergence of the idea of the divine
individual that's essentially what it is
and we we have a very uneasy
relationship with that collection of
texts now because they we read them as
if they're making claims about the
objective nature of the world and those
claims seem to be false from a
scientific perspective I don't believe
that those are the claims that
made to begin with so I think it's a
non-starter but I've been trying to
lecture about the stories in Genesis for
example in a manner that makes them
accessible to people who are well to
Athey who a theist let's say and many
many atheists have been responding very
positively to them I have people in my
youtube comments now that are calling
themselves Christian atheists because
they can understand they understand what
it is I'm describing this idea that's
emerged in the West that consciousness
is the mediator between chaos and order
and the and the and that generating the
phenomena that generates experience and
that and that you can think about that
as as a divine category of existence and
I've been trying to delineate how how
the biblical stories lay out the pathway
by which the divine individual should
manifest him or herself in time because
that is what it is and I and I I've been
studying for example the Abrahamic
stories which I didn't know well and the
Abrahamic stories are really interesting
I mean Abraham is called by God and when
Abraham is called by God he's old he's
like one of these guys who's 40 years
old and his stayed in his mother's
basement that's that's Abraham it's a
little late for Abraham to be getting
the hell out there in the world and God
basically says to him leave your family
and your friends and your place of
comfort and journey into the land of the
stranger that's the call to adventure
and so Abraham does that now he's chosen
by God you think well everything goes
well for Abraham that isn't what happens
at all
the first thing he encounters is a
famine and to escape that he flees into
the tyranny of Egypt where they try to
steal his wife
it's like beware of being called by God
you know you'd think it'd be all
sweetness and light after that it's not
that at all it's a very realistic story
it's like get the hell out of where
you're safe into what you don't know
what are you gonna find there well your
fortune no you're gonna find the
catastrophes of life but if you keep
yourself morally oriented and you make
the right sacrifices which is the the
Abrahamic story to a tee then you can
transcend the catastrophe of being and
prevail
I mean it's who the hell doesn't want to
hear that so we're treading kind of
close to the
the argument she got into was Sam Harris
about the nature of truth and and since
I heard that I've been sort of itching
to have this conversation with you
because I think there's a a way of
viewing this that will actually perhaps
reconcile the two points of view but
there's a bitter pill that comes along
with it so here's here's my argument we
tend to think of intellect has evolved
as having evolved because knowing what's
true gives you an advantage but there's
actually nothing that says the literal
truth is where advantage lies and so I
have a category that I call literally
false metaphorically true these are
ideas that aren't true in the factual
sense but they are true enough that if
you behave as if they were true you come
out ahead of where you would be if you
behaved according to the fact that
they're not true so let me give you a
couple of trivial examples that won't be
controversial porcupines can throw their
quills not true however if you live near
porcupines and you imagine that
porcupines can throw their quills you'll
give them some space if you don't you
may realize and that they can throw
other quills get really close to one and
it may wheel around and nail you with a
porcupine quill which can be extremely
dangerous because they are
microscopically designed to move in from
where they puncture you over time and
they can puncture a vital organ or you
can get an infection so the person who
believes that a porcupine can throw
their quills has an advantage that isn't
predicated on the fact that this is
actually a literal truth right another
one might be people say everything
happens for a reason right well unless
you're talking about physics as the
reason everything doesn't happen for a
reason however if you are the kind of
person who believes that everything
happens for a reason and then some
terrible tragedy befalls you you may be
on the lookout well what's the reason
that this happened maybe it's supposed
to open some opportunity and you won't
miss that opportunity the way somebody
who was preoccupied with their
misfortune would so literal falseness
but metaphorical truth is actually I
would argue the category
under which religious truth evolves
now the problem the bitter pill that I
mentioned is that I've heard you say
that the truths that are captured in the
the religious version of things are
basically like you know there's an
individual truth and then there's a
truth of your family and there's the
truth of the population that you're
living in and these things are all
encoded in these these doctrines which
is true and you would expect it to be
because the doctrines are carried along
in the population
the problem is what I hear you arguing
when you tell me if I have it wrong is
that we should therefore expect the
encoded metaphorical truths in these
religious traditions to be morally right
but there's nothing that actually says
it will be morally right because there
are metaphorical truths that might in
fact be reprehensible but nonetheless
effective and so what I would argue the
overarching point here would be that
you're right that the documents that
contain these descriptions of things are
full of things that are true in some
sense that is not literal scientific
truth nor was that their their purpose
what isn't true is that those things are
inherently up-to-date and see I would
okay I mean first of all the first thing
about that is that a discussion like
that and this is also what happened with
Sam Harris takes me to the very limits
of my intellectual ability and so even
in discussing it I'm going to make all
sorts of mistakes because because it's
treacherous territory but I would say my
understanding of the great myths has
that observation built into it so one of
the archetypes is that of the of the
tyrannical father which is the archetype
by the way that possesses the minds of
people who accuse Western society of
being patriarchal they're possessed by a
singular archetype and that's the
archetype of the tyrannical father they
don't see that there's a tyrannical
father and a wise king because there is
that's that's you can't even point that
out but anyways in the in the old in in
some of our oldest or
there's a representation of the dead
past so let me give you an example that
everyone knows about the story of
Pinocchio is the story of the
individualization of Pinocchio he starts
out as a puppet he's a marionette
he's a wooden head he's a liar and he's
pulled by forces that he does not
understand right ok so but he has a good
father
that's Geppetto and so he's got a good
and Geppetto wishes that he becomes a
real individual and so and he knows that
that's an impossible wish he wishes on a
star that his son could become an actual
individual knowing full well that that's
unlikely and impossible so Geppetto is a
good king so but the story is also about
Geppetto because what happens is that
when Geppetto loses Pinocchio loses his
son which way you could think about as
the act of dynamic attentive force of
youth then he ends up stultified in the
belly of a whale which is a symbol of
chaos at the bottom of the ocean and
then Pinocchio has to rescue him so I
would say there is an instantiation of
evolutionarily accumulated wisdom in the
great stories of the past but they're
still dead and it requires the Union
this is why in Christian theology the
the Godhead has a tripartite structure
this is part of the reason there's God
the Father but the father's dead the
father was right a hundred years ago a
thousand years ago and is still partly
right but he's dead he can't participate
in the updating of the process so you
need an active force now the active
force is the same thing that generated
those stories across time right so it's
it's the same thing except it's also
alive in the present and so your moral
duty and this is another thing that
happens and in Pinocchio is to rescue
your dead father from the belly of the
whale and that's partly what I'm trying
to do with these biblical lectures
because your objection is correct
the reason it's correct is because even
if the solution was correct the
landscape has changed and it's changed
incremental iorry in a revolutionary way
we don't know and so those old truths
are at best partial and at worst blind
but that doesn't mean you can just say
like like Mao did during the Cultural
Revolution well let's just destroy the
past it's like no that would be like
saying well you don't need a body
anymore because your body is the
collected wisdom of the evolutionary
process across three and a half
billion years I absolutely agree because
the stories are not literal it's
impossible to know whether they well not
impossible but very difficult to know
whether or not the truth that is
contained metaphorically is still
relevant if it's been inverted and it's
now absolutely false or so Carl Jung
talked about this a lot and and one of
the things he said was that your moral
duty is to realize the archetype in the
in the confines of your own life and so
you say well there's an archetype of
perfection that pervades the West and
for that for the sake of argument I'm
going to call that Christ the Christ
image it's something like that that's
the archetypal image now we have a story
about what Christ's historical life was
like well well well you can't have that
life because you would have had to be in
the Middle East 2,000 years ago that's
not your life but what you can do is
take the archetypal and you can manifest
it was within the confines of your own
life and what that does is force you to
undergo the difficult process of
updating the ancient wisdom and you
don't just forego it you can't or you
can but you'll pay a massive price and
part of that will be social
disintegration because it's it's the the
past is alive enough so that those of us
who inhabit its corpse aren't clawing
each other to death while we're feeding
right that's the critical issue now it's
not alive enough because the bloody
thing could fall apart at any moment and
we need to be awake and alert in order
to keep it updated and maintained well
not only that but they're the greatest
hazards to us in the present are only
partially going to be dealt with in
these texts and that's that's my biggest
concern is that you know if we take you
know Dawkins dismissing religion as mind
virus this is very dangerous because it
neglects the truth that you're talking
about and it prevents us from getting to
a conversation in which we can talk
about the fact that religious texts
religions are not mind viruses they are
adaptations to past environments they do
contain a kind of truth that isn't
necessarily literal and is in general
not literal but none of them no ancient
religion is up-to-date for Google's
algorithms being the hazard to
civilization that it probably is we need
to
figure out how to navigate where the
ancestral wisdom is simply not up to the
current okay so let me modify that
slightly because I think it's true and
not true the stories are erroneous in
detail and right in pattern so for
example there's an idea that one of the
things that the mythological hero does
is stand up against the tyranny of the
state now you don't have to specify the
nature of the tyranny of the state in
order for that to be a truth that's
applicable across different context I
would say what's happened with the great
religious myths is that they've they
operate at a level of abstraction such
that the the abstract entities are
applicable in every single environment
I'll give you an example of that it is
extremely useful to represent the
phenomenology of your experience as a
domain of chaos and order that works in
every single environment for every
person and so the domain of order I can
describe it technically you're in the
domain of order when your actions
produce the result you desire and you're
in the domain of chaos when they don't
and then and then I could say well your
task is to straddle the border between
those two domains because you don't
always want to be where everything that
you're doing is working because you
don't learn anything and you don't want
to be where nothing you're doing is
working because it's overwhelming you
want to be stable and dynamic at the
same point and the Daoists do that very
nicely because they have a chaos order
conceptualization of the of the
phenomenological landscape and their
claim is the the point of maximum proper
being is right at the center of the
border between chaos and order and I
think that's true across contexts so I
don't think that truth ages some of them
don't but the question really is one of
at what point is there so much legacy
code that the taking the package is is
more harmful than it is beneficial and
at what point are you know if god were
writing today I'm pretty convinced the
first commandment would be thou shalt
not enrich uranium it would make sense
as the number one commandment it's not
there because uranium wasn't a concept
at the point that the thing was written
nor was the hazard of enriching it
obvious and so the fact that it isn't
mentioned tends to de-emphasize it as a
risk and so I guess the question is is
it possible I mean is it possible that
by recognizing that these traditions
carry huge amounts of ancestral wisdom
forward but that that wisdom is certain
to be so incomplete that it doesn't
address modern questions that we can be
liberated to move forward and to honor
those traditions for bringing us here
but to recognize that we actually have
to move forward with something more
potent and up to date which is not not
easy because you can't just take the
scientific truth of the moment and
implement a lot of it isn't even right
it's yeah it's also not that easy to
rewrite a fairy tale you know and I'm
some of these fairy tales that people
are trying to rewrite in modern times
are perhaps fifteen thousand years old
and people think well we can just update
that so that the modern version will be
better it turns out that that's very
very difficult and there's another I'm
gonna play devil's advocate against my
own position here no because I say well
the religious texts encode profound and
evolutionarily determined truths that
are universal okay which religious texts
right well because you might say well
all of them but then that means that
obscures the important differences
between the traditions and I'm by no
means certain that all of them do you
know so I'm going to stick my neck way
the hell out because why not it isn't
obvious to me that Islam does because I
it's very difficult for me to see that
the totalizing nature of Islam doesn't
make it unique among religions so now
good so well there's that out on the
tape if you don't mind
but isn't the issue using the word truth
because we can say true we could use
tradition and wisdom and we're okay but
as soon as we start saying truth then
then we run into problems I mean and
even when you're talking about
porcupines well you talk about what
would you say metaphorical truth versus
look it's not true it's real simple just
don't go near the porcupine teach the
kid to not go near the porcupine because
porcupine quills are dangerous they get
stuck in you they're really dangerous
can they throw it out you know they
cannot but just stay clear of them
because you don't want them to somehow
another get in touch with your body
there's no truth in that they can throw
their quills at you you benefit from
being particularly aware of the dangers
of their quills but if you tell a kid
that they can throw their quills and so
therefore the kid stays clear of them
here's a faulty assumption in his head
you're lying to them for their own
protection and I was not good I wouldn't
do it I think the same thing could be
said of everything happens for a reason
well here's the problem we don't know if
everything happens for a reason maybe
when you die you go to some auditing
room and they go well you know it's all
just a part of some gigantic algorithm
that you're impossible it's impossible
for you to understand due to your
limited processing power of the human
brain you're dealing with some simian
sort of complex geometry that's really
just design to keep your body move you
can keep you alive and spread your
genetics so that you can eventually
evolve to the point when you're a god
well first of all I I have kids I would
write on them that a porcupine I'm sure
he's wills but how do I use the word
truth though ah because well the
question is why do people tell you that
a porcupine can throw its quills I don't
think they do oh they do well if they do
they don't know any better right or
they're liars right and so all I'm
saying is that actually that is likely
to be the product of selection in other
words that those people who had encoded
that they do throw their quills have an
advantage it's not the way I wouldn't do
it and for exactly the reason that you
point out which is if you give a child
the wrong model of a porcupine I don't
know whether a porcupine is liable to be
the Gateway to some more important
question but if it were
you've just steered the kid wrong well
something here's part of the problem and
this is part of but and this is a really
big problem there's two things I guess
that were brought up by what you
described and the first is the
terminology of truth now
Harris's claim with regards to my
utilization of truth was that I was
absconded with the definition of truth
and in false matter but he was wrong
because the idea of truth is much older
than the idea of objective truth and the
original notion of truth wasn't
objective true it was like the arrow
flies straight and true right it meant
something like
reliably reliably on its way to the
appropriate destination something like
that and when Christ said I am the truth
in the way what I can't remember either
yes yes the truth he was talking about
wasn't an objective truth so Sam's idea
that I had somehow you know taken the
idea of truth that was actually
objective all along and done something
crooked with it is just wrong it's wrong
well there's no truth can have multiple
definitions well that maybe there was
that that's the issue and that's exactly
what we're what we're trying to get out
here is like there's to me there's two
kinds of truth and and they may be they
may be commensurate you may be able to
stack them on top of one another but now
and then they dissociate and this is
actually what what what Brett was
referring to as well so so and this is
where it gets so complicated that I can
barely manage it there's a there's the
truth that manifests itself in the
manner in which you act and there's the
truth that manifests itself as a
representation of the objective world
and sometimes both those truths are
stacked on top of each other and
sometimes they're not so like I could
give you a piece of wisdom that would
work well if you acted it out that
carried within it an inaccurate
representation of part of the objective
world and you could say well maybe
that's actually the case with the
biblical stories because if you read
them as science they don't read well so
let's take malaria as a good example
malaria the root of the word is mal area
bad air right malaria is not transmitted
by bad air to transmitted by mosquitoes
that live in places where you might
think the air is bad so the point is
it's part of the way there yeah that's a
good one and that also gets see there's
another weird distinction here and that
I was trying to draw with Sam but that's
a really tricky one and we ordered in
because we started to talk about
pragmatism but there's also something
like the truth of a description and the
truth of a tool and my sense is that
people's fundamental truths are too
alike we use them to function properly
in the world and you could say well a
sharp axe is more true than a dull axe
and actually you can use the word true
in that sense that actually isn't
appropriate appropriate use of the word
there there are tool truths and there
are
objective fact truth now and in the
optimal circumstance those map on to
each other but we're not smart enough
often to make the map on to each other
because we just don't know enough and
there are lots of truths that we have
that portray the objective world
improperly that are still true is this
problem using the term true when
sometimes you should use the term fact
like yes one plus one is two that is a
fact one plus one is two is also true
you throw some water on a match that is
and it will go out that's a fact
yes well as I see it at least there is
this overarching truth the one that sam
harris was pointing to the one i think
you're pointing to also and the one i
i'm imagining we all subscribe to sure
right there is the testable truth that
reveals itself in the laboratory were in
a careful experiment in the field and
that really is the top level truth but
then there are the truths you can't
speak yet so let's take the word filth
from from the old testament okay
filth means [ __ ] right you're not
supposed to [ __ ] in camp because god
finds it offensive now the problem is
the germ theory of disease doesn't come
about for thousands of years after that
truth was written that truth keeps you
from infecting people long before you
can ever explain that there are microbes
that grow in human [ __ ] that are a
particular danger to your population so
the point is would you rather be held
back to the place where you can actually
describe the literal underpinnings of
what's going on or do you want to be
liberated to say something that actually
results in an improvement in health
before you know literally thousands of
years before anybody had any idea that
it was microbes at the root of this yes
no need to figure out so an elaboration
of that would be something like human
beings needed to figure out how to act
without dying before they could
understand the nature of the world well
enough to justify that right and
somebody might be crazy now that we do
have the germ theory of disease to to
amplify that original crude version of
the truth or that crude approximation of
what you need to believe in order to
behave safely there's no reason for that
truth
to be promoted in fact you don't hear
people describing this part of the Old
Testament relevant right and this is
probably all why dietary restrictions
were in the Old Testament as well
shellfish red tide eating pigs
trichinosis there's a lot of a lot of
issues that go along with that yeah well
there is some intermingling perhaps of
hygienic concerns with also the desire
for the groups to distinguish themselves
from other groups right because you can
you can unite your group quite tightly
by dietary restrictions so um back to
your point about terminology you know we
could we could do something like fact
and wisdom you know you say truth that's
the overarching category and then that
divides into fact and wisdom and what
you want optimally is you want the facts
and the wisdom to be one not one to one
but often they're not and if you find
wisdom where the facts aren't laid right
out you don't just get to throw away the
wisdom which is what I think happens in
the case of people like Dawkins and
Harris and Harris makes another
sleight-of-hand move which I don't like
which is that he thinks so let's say
except for just a second the wisdom fact
distinction he would say well the fact
is the thing and the wisdom is a second
order derivation of that you can ground
the wisdom in the fact and I don't
believe that and I don't think that he
has he I don't think that he has any
real justification for that claim and
this is something by grounding the
wisdom in the fact he thinks if you know
the facts clearly enough you'll know how
to act well that's not necessarily true
well there's ways to act with that are
within your best interest and then
there's ways to act that are within the
interest of all the people around you've
been might not serve you that well well
this diction is where ethics come right
or right where the consequences are
delayed yes some number of generations
sure thing like yes well that's a big
problem and right so so Sam acts as if
the process of mac mapping facts onto
action is simple if we just got the
facts right but but it's the weakest
part of his argument and we never ever
got to that for a variety of reasons but
part of the reason it's weak is okay
well there's like an infinite number of
facts man which so let's say you're
standing in front of a field and you're
looking at the field the field does not
tell you how to walk through it there's
a million ways through the field and
matter how many facts about the field
you aggregate you're not going to be
able to determine the appropriate path
by aggregating those facts so it's
that's and that that's a problem that I
don't think Sam is willing to take
seriously and well I think there are two
problems tangled up here one of them is
there's a question of re is one
individual supposed to have all of the
facts and navigate based on on that sort
of the rationality community version of
things or does you know the practical
truth is we can't all be experts in
everything and so we have to go along
with you know guides to our behavior
that are approximate and that that's
inherent and then there's a question
about civilization civilization should
be guided by our best understanding of
what's actually true but with an
understanding that we don't have a
complete map of a lot of stuff and so I
think what you're pointing at is that
there is wisdom that has been handed to
us that is not such that we can just
simply say oh here's the nugget at the
center of it and we need to preserve
that thing because we don't necessarily
know what it's doing yeah which is you
know that's this is dangerous because
some of what it's doing may not be
acceptable well and think about let's
look at the wisdom end of things for a
minute you talk you've alluded a little
earlier to like iterations and and and
about the fact that things are iterated
across time and that's something that
works now might fail dreadfully in a
month or two months so so here's here's
what something has to be like to be wise
let's say well first of all let's say it
would be good if as it was in accordance
with the facts but we'll leave that
aside for now it has to work if you
operate according to the wisdom
principle whatever it is it has to work
in the world but then it has to work in
a world that allows you to maintain your
relationships with people in the world
right so it's all of a sudden this
wisdom thing is something that's not
only constrained by let's call it
objective reality but it's constrained
by the necessity of a social contract a
functional social contract so you're
only able to you're only allowed to put
forward actions in the world that would
be of benefit to you if they
simultaneously don't undermine the
structure within which you live okay and
then there's a game theory element to
that which is
if it's wise then it works in the world
so that'd be the constraint of objective
reality but then it works for you now
and the you that'll be in a week and the
you that'll be in a month and it works
for you and your family and it works for
you and your family and society and it
works in a way that those things all
line up to be iterated across time and
so this this is actually they're all so
the solution is for and I'd really like
to hear what you think about this I
think this is the solution to the
postmodern conundrum because the post
modernists bless their heart so we'll
give the devil his due
say well the problem is there's an
infinite number of interpretations of a
finite set of facts and the right
response to that is oh oh that's true
that's true that's not good and that's
why the postmodern to say well you can't
agree on a canonical interpretation of a
great piece of literature because the
number of potential interpretations are
infinite and so then they say well why
should we settle on any one
interpretation then why should we
privilege one over another and then they
say well that's all power games and so
that's our you got to take that
seriously but what they missed and this
is a big deal it's a big deal I think is
this idea of ethical constraint it's
like yes there's a landscape of
potentially infinite interpretations but
hardly any of them will work in the real
world and hardly any of them will work
in the real world in a way that doesn't
get you killed by other people or doom
you because of your own stupidity to
failure across time and so the landscape
of interpretation is almost infinite but
the landscape of applicable
interpretation functional interpretation
is unbelievably constrained and I think
that constraint system is what we regard
as ethics it's something like that well
at some level stories continue through
time for a reason you know good stories
continue for a long you know the Odyssey
is with us for some reason and we so
there is a scientific reason or a
scientifically
investigative reason why the Odyssey has
been durable we may not know it but it's
a in principle it's a question you could
investigate so I guess yeah at the end
of the day the problem with the
postmodernist is that they have a point
the point is perception gets in the way
of anything we wish to do objectively
but that point only takes you so far and
that's why they turned to Marx's
as far as I can tell because what
happens with the postmodernist as they
say oh there's an infinite number of
interpretations and then the human part
of them goes okay well what am I
supposed to do next then since there's
an infinite number of choices and the
postmodernist says well my theory can't
account for that and then they say well
back to Marxism and so that's why I
think there's this unholy alliance
between the post modernists and the
neo-marxists is because post-modernism
is a is a dead end from the perspective
of applicable wisdom it leaves you
bereft and nihilistic and that's not
good because people can't exist without
a purpose and so they sneak the Marxism
through the back door and and jump into
this power landscape for the reasons
that we discussed earlier you really
think that it's because of an infinite
number of possibilities interpretating
things because I've always felt that it
was really just a response to capitalism
they feel that capitalism is a very
negative aspect of our culture and
society and that there's got to be some
sort of an alternative Marxism is a
clearly defined alternative that other
people have subscribed to in the past
you could point to it it's a structure
that's already already set up and it's
romanticized
and I think they adopt it for that
reason because it has a socialist
aspects attached to it and they looked
at socialism as it's some sort of a
thing that regards equality and you know
it's some sort of an egalitarian
approach well it's okay so we'd have to
take two things apart we'd have to take
Marxism slash neo-marxist Marxism and
post-modernism apart so we could do that
historically and I would say that
although there is a reason for
post-modernism which is the reason we
just discussed that the the landscape
the infinite landscape of interpretation
problem it's a real problem if you look
at it historically post-modernism
actually grew out of Marxism and so what
what happened is that the Marxists laid
out their their their theory about the
human social environment being composed
of a power struggle between the
privileged and the underprivileged right
the rich and the poor and in its initial
phases and that's a story that's
partially true and it's got a lot of
motive power like the motive power is
the romantic motive power that you just
described I get to be on the side of the
oppressed I get to be a war
for what's right there's the resentment
element which is that son-of-a-bitch has
more than me so let's cut them off at
the knees which manifested itself
brutally in the Soviet Union and then
there's the ideological totality issue
which gives people a sense of security
that took a vicious hit by it by the
late 1960s because the murderous nosov
Marxism had been clearly laid out as a
doctrine and that opened the door to
this move by by mostly French
intellectuals to to develop the
postmodern philosophy which has these
advantages which we described but but
also to use that as a screening tactic
for allowing Marxism to transform into
identity politics and so it like it's
hard to disentangle all the motivations
that are going on in there but there's
something about it that's that's truly
intellectually pathological because you
don't get to be a postmodernist and a
Marxist you actually technically cannot
be both of those things at the same time
and the fact that most people are both
of those things at the same time raises
the specter of just exactly what their
motivation is and then I would say it's
this resentment driven anti capitalism
there's reasons to criticize capitalism
obviously but it's this underground
resentment driven anti capitalism that I
think is one of the fundamental
motivators well if I can if I can add a
couple things the risk of alienating my
last few friends so here's the thing
what's up with with Marxism is a there's
a lot in marx critique of capitalism
that's actually right and so that kind
of gets you through the door once you
start looking at the analysis and then
there's the prescription which is toxic
but it's not obvious why it's toxic in
other words it's a pretty good story
that doesn't happen to function and so
people gravitate to it because the story
is moderately compelling it's not game
theoretically functional or stable or
viable and it does descend into this
kind of you know inevitable grave
violence and so we know that now
historically it's not just a theoretical
issue we've now seen enough of it to
know that there's a fact but nonetheless
the fact that there are people telling
the story to
kids who don't yet know what to do with
something that sounds like it might be
true is very dangerous if you don't mind
break it down as to why it goes bad well
I mean it's sort of a tired critique but
I happen to think it's about right which
is that it just does not take account of
what the human being is and what makes
society function spoken like a true
fascist well I think it might be related
back to ok so let's go back to the idea
that Marx had something to say ok and we
could clarify that a little bit so
here's a problem this is the problem
that it seems to emerge as the function
of some really fundamental force that we
don't quite understand and that's this
phenomena that I've been referring to as
the Pareto distribution ok so here's the
here's the situation if you look at any
creative endeavor that human beings
engage in so that would be an endeavor
where there's variability and individual
production it doesn't matter what it is
here's what happens people compete to
produce whatever that is and almost
everybody produces zero they lose
completely a small minority are a tiny
bit successful and a hyper minority are
insanely successful and so the Pareto
distribution for and the Pareto
distribution is is the what geometric
graph representation of that phenomena
and so here's how it manifests itself if
you have ten thousand people a hundred
of them have half the money so the rule
is the square root of the number of
people under consideration have half of
whatever it is that's under
consideration so this works everywhere
so if you took a hundred classical
composers ten of them produce half the
music that's played and then if you take
the ten composers and you take a
thousand of their songs thirty of those
songs which is the square root of a
thousand roughly speaking are played
fifty percent of the time and so there's
this underlying natural law which is
it's expressed as the Matthieu principle
which is from a New Testament statement
the statement is
those who have everything more will be
given and from those who have nothing
everything will be taken it's a vicious
statement but it's it's actually here's
one of those places where it's actually
empirically true this happens everywhere
and so what Marx observed was that
capital tended to accumulate in the
hands of fewer and fewer people and he
said that's a flaw of the capitalist
system that's wrong it's not a flaw of
the capitalist system it is a feature of
every single system of production that
we know of no matter who set it up and
how it operates and so and then now we
have a problem because what happens is
as soon as you set up a domain of
production and you need to because you
need things to be produced then you
instantly produce a competition and the
spoils go disproportionately to a tiny
percentage of people so then the quiz
yeah so then well so what well so the
rest of the people starve or the system
becomes unstable because everybody's mad
it's like that's a big problem ok so how
do human beings fix that well the first
thing we did was diversify the number of
productive games so you don't get to be
NBA basketball star but you know you can
run a podcast it's a completely
different competitive landscape so we
can fractionate the the production
landscape and then people who aren't
successful in one domain might be
successful in others
that's create human creativity we're
really good at that but the problem with
that is you can still get a positive
correlation among the successful people
you know so because you're so successful
for example with your podcast in your
YouTube videos your connection network
is insane insanely powerful right so you
still have this tendency for what's
useful and good to be what distributed
let's call it inequitably and it's it's
it's got the power of a physical law in
fact there are people they call
themselves econo physicists no one knows
that there's a field econo physicists
econo physics and they use the same
mathematical equations that that
represent the propagation of molecules
into a gas molecules into a vacuum to
describe the manner in which money
distributes itself in an economy
ok so Marx pointed to a fundamental
issue but he said well that's a fault
with capitalism it's like no it isn't
it's something way more pernicious than
that and it's it's something like well
when one good thing
Institute makes you a little more
powerful and attractive and so that
fractionally increases the possibility
that another good thing will happen to
you and then that spirals out of control
and you get people who have well they
have all the money or they have all the
podcast downloads you're in that
position you know what is it 1.2 billion
like what the hell but it's to those who
have more and it's not because there's
something oppressive about you it's
because you you rode the wave of the
Pareto distribution in it and it threw
you way that way the hell up into the
stratosphere and we don't know what to
do about that like should you be sharing
your podcast views with the with the
oppressed and downtrodden
I mean you've well you've got a few
billion you could spread the damn things
around it's not fair that you're the
only one that's being listened to you
know it's the same argument and it's a
compelling argument because why the hell
should you have all that power if you
call it power you could call it
authority or competence this is not a
different argument because no one's
asking anyone to download anything in
specific no ones no one's compelling
anyone to download anything specific you
could download whatever you want and if
you put more effort in more time and
more focus into your work whatever it
would be whether it's a podcast or your
YouTube videos or whatever if people
enjoy it they gravitate towards it and
then over time it exponentially
increases the amount of people that are
exposed to well this is why I think that
the and this is the other problem with
the Marxist perspective is that and the
post modernists in particular like they
conflate power competence and authority
unfairly now your point it's sort of the
point of free marketers you're saying
well look all I'm doing is offering a
product I'm not compelling anyone it's a
quality product or at least as far as
the market is concerned it is if it
turns out that everyone wants that well
what's wrong with that and I'm not
disagreeing with that argument in the
least but but it's the problem is it
doesn't it doesn't fix the problem like
the problem with money let's say the
problem is is that if you let a monetary
system run all the money ends up in the
hands of a very few number of people and
you're saying this is also with any sort
of creative it any creative endeavor man
now what is wrong like I think the real
issue would be to maximize potential
output or maximize the amount of
successful people
you have to figure out what's don't
concentrate on what people are doing
right
concentrate on what people are doing
wrong like what why what are the people
doing wrong that are failing whether in
any crew that's why we put together just
to be one at all that's partly why we
put together the Future authoring
program because we are trying to figure
out what made people successful and one
of the things that makes people
successful is they specify a target and
then aim at it right because if you're
all over the place
in a relatively functional society like
ours we know what predicts success IQ
and conscientiousness are the biggest
predictors of success now there's a
genetic lottery thing going on there
that's kind of rough but it does say
that smart people who work hard are
disproportionately likely to succeed and
then you might also say well you want to
remove the impediments from people who
have those capabilities so that they can
move forward and one one of the
predictors of success as well is to
decide what your success is going to be
and then work hard in that direction and
that actually works so I think that is a
very useful thing to do and that's well
like I said that's partly why we've been
working in that direction so but it
there's other problems that it doesn't
still still doesn't solve like one of
them is if you don't have any money it's
really hard to get some like once you
have some it's not so hard to get some
more all right but if you're at zero
Jesus man you're in this you're in the
reverse situation mm-hmm you're poor you
don't have anything no one wants to talk
to you you can't get out of it because
you're too poor to get out of it you
know you're penalized by the economic
system because you can't even afford to
start playing the game you're stuck at
zero you're stuck at zero and you can't
get out and the revolutionary types you
know they go to the people who are stuck
at zero and they say hey you're stuck at
zero why don't you burn the whole
goddamn thing to the ground right
because maybe in the next iteration you
won't be stuck at zero and for young men
that's a hell of a call right because
they're already let's call them
expendable
biologically and that makes them more
adventurous and risk-taking if someone
says and maybe that's why they wear the
Che Guevara t-shirt it's like hey I'm
stuck at zero well I'd rather be with
the romantic who's burning the whole
thing to the ground than to just you
know to stay locked in my immobile
position right but that's
was where massive amounts of creativity
come from because of that struggle
massive amounts of innovation massive
amounts of people who have visions
because you're not living off of some
sort of trust fund you know you you have
real risk in real danger and you have a
real concern about your future where
someone who has no concerns whatsoever
and their future is carved in stone they
could do whatever they want buy a new
Ferrari every year that they're not
gonna have nearly the amount of
motivation as the poor person yeah.well
that may be why family fortunes tend to
only last three generations yes and you
know you're saying well why don't you
take a look at the advantages of zero
and one of the advantages is there is
that you're driven by brute necessity
and that can really be motivating and
that's I think why why first the
children of first generation immigrants
often do so well yes you know they're
driven by necessity and it's risk so yes
agreed however I would still say you
know the zero issue is there are levels
of absolute privation that are so
intense yes
that all the goodwill in the world won't
get you out of zero right if you're
living in a third-world country in some
very small village with no way out
whatsoever that is the zero of zero
right Tanzania on the on the river
people getting eaten by crocodiles in
your village you're [ __ ]
yes zero is like a magnet yeah just hold
yeah it's a black hole having a little
very little maybe that motivational
state actually generative right there's
a difference and then what's really
bizarre is those people in that village
might be happier than the people who
live in a gated community in Beverly
Hills well I wanted to I wanted to come
back to this your point about about
whether we should be concentrating on
what you're doing right versus what
you're doing wrong both of those will
work and you should actually be doing
both of them simultaneously you'll
you'll maximize faster but the real
problem is that the system in which we
concentrate on what you're doing right
and what you're doing wrong and
supposedly you get paid for some
integration of those things is that we
don't we don't understand what we are
wired to produce evolutionarily right we
think we all operate they
the idea that we're pursuing some state
of happiness or satisfaction and you
know we we think we know what's going to
get it for us and maybe it's inventing
something and then then you'll be happy
but it's a trap the fact is what we are
wired to do is to discover opportunities
and then when we discover an opportunity
it benefits the population that we come
from and we turn that discovery into our
more mouths to feed or more consumption
and we restore the state of privation
right we restore the state in which
people don't have enough and so if you
really wanted to fix this problem if you
wanted to address the problems that
communism thinks its solving but fails
too you have to engineer around this
this feature of human beings where we
pursue new opportunities and as soon as
we find a new opportunity instead of
figuring out a way to stabilize the
benefits so that it results in a stable
sense of satisfaction for example we
fall all over ourselves to turn it into
more of the same because of course
that's how we got here can you give me
example which mean buzz I'm sure so
let's look at something like the let's
imagine an ancient farmer ancient farmer
has a piece of land and that piece of
land will support a certain number of
people with the level of technology that
the farmer is utilizing somehow the
farmer ends up either thinking of or
discovering by watching somebody else a
wheel now that farmer has a technology
that allows him or however many people
are working that farm to produce that
much more food with no more labor
because the wheel allows you to
transport more for example at one time
so now that same piece of land can
support more people because it can be
more efficiently farmed that could be
stabilized as a kind of success in other
words that you could turn the extra the
surplus into a kind of persistent luxury
yeah a luxury but I mean I don't even
luxury is a little bit too trivial
sounding you could turn it into a space
where you
use that to to investigate important
stuff or you could turn it into more
mouths to feed in which case as soon as
you've produced those extra mouths that
are now consuming the output of that
farm now the level of you know fear of
starvation is right back where it was
mm-hmm and so so so that's more money
more problems yeah essentially I mean
you know well it used to be that we
produced more people now we produce a
greater quest for consumption right but
if we were smart what we would do is we
would think about the problem of how to
take the gains that come from not being
bumped up at the limits of a system and
turn them into what we value all right
we've we've done some of that I mean
because so we've done some of that
because as what do they say a rising
tide lifts all ships and there's
certainly some truth in that the overall
standard of living has gone up so
stupendously since 1895 that it's an
absolute miracle so we've done some of
that
so there's another issue back to Marx
let's say there's another issue that we
have we can't contend with and one of
those might be well imagine that in
order for society to progress you have
to allow the individual to compete in a
relatively untrammeled space so that
they can innovate and then imagine that
one of the consequences of that
innovation is that you get these preeto
distributions developing because the
innovator or the one who's second in
line to the innovator whatever ends up
with them with the bulk of the spoils so
you might say there's a cost to be paid
in inequality for innovation and then
you could also say well too much
inequality destabilizes things which
seems to be quite quite clear so there's
room for an intelligent conversation
about that right because the lefties say
Oh too much inequality and they need to
be listened to because the evidence is
quite clear if you let the inequality
ramp up enough the whole system
destabilizes because the people at the
bottom think [ __ ] it we'll just we'll
just flip the system upside down right
no one wants that
like right-wing conservatives don't want
that so because you could make a
Republican argument say don't let the
inequality in your neighborhood
out of hand because the crime rate will
skyrocket and the empirical evidence on
that is overwhelmingly strong inequality
drives crime now you can say you can
argue about why but the fact that it
does is that's not disputable so we can
have an intelligent discussion between
the left and the right and the
discussion would go something like this
you need innovation you pay for
innovation with inequality but you need
to bind inequality because if it's too
intense then things destabilize it's
like okay we could agree on that we've
got the parameters set now we have to
now we have to start thinking very
carefully through how to do the
redistribution issue and we don't know
how to do that so you might say well we
have a guaranteed annual income for
people which i think is a horrible
solution by the way but it addresses the
right problem the problem is is that
we're hyper productive but the spoils go
to those at the top and some of those
resources need to be funneled down to
the people who have zero so that they
have an opportunity to at least get to
the point where they can innovate and so
the bloody whole bloody thing doesn't
wobble and fall and we could we and I
would say in some sense that's what the
political discussion is about but we
we've we've skittered off into these
radical oversimplifications which is
something like well if if you have more
than another person you're an oppressor
and you're evil and if you have less
it's because you're virtuous and
victimized and that's just a non-starter
so you think that there's a real problem
with like something like a universal
basic income
well I think the idea that the solution
is a basic income is not a good idea
because I think the problem is deeper
than that I I don't think the
fundamental problem is that people don't
have enough money I think the
fundamental problem is that human beings
in some sense are beasts of burden and
if they're not given if they're not
provided with a place where they can
accept social responsibility social and
individual responsibility in an
honourable manner they degenerate and
die but that's the opiate crisis in West
right now like men need men who are men
don't need money they need function and
we've got a problem one of the problems
is for example here here's an ugly stat
I think I told you this once before it's
illegal to induct anyone into the Armed
Forces if they have an IQ of less than
83 and the reason for that is the you
know the armed force
despite having every reason to draw the
contradictory conclusion has decided
that there isn't a single thing that you
can be trained to do in the military if
you have an IQ of less than 83 that
isn't positively counterproductive
that's ten percent of the population and
we're producing a culture that's very
cognitively complex like what the hell
are you gonna do if you can't use a
computer like if you can use a computer
you're at least in the game if you can
really use one you're hyper powerful if
you're not literate enough to use a
computer you're at zero ten percent of
the population the Conservatives say
well there's a job for everyone if they
just worked hard enough it's like ah no
and increasingly no and the Liberals say
well everyone's basically the same and
you can train anyone to do anything it's
like no you can't yeah I want to go back
to the inequality point here because if
you look at this biologically actually I
think it gave reveals a lot why are we I
mean we know from from careful study
that people are motivated by the degree
of inequality more than they are the the
absolute level of well-being that they
have and there's a very good it's tragic
but a very good evolutionary reason for
this which is if you are working on some
piece of land and your neighbor has the
adjacent piece of land and they're doing
twice as well as you it's because they
know something you don't right and so
becoming focused on what they're doing
that you're not doing is a rational
thing to spend your time on so you can
figure out what it is that they know
that you don't in the modern environment
this is a catastrophe because who are
your neighbors well you've got some box
sitting on the wall of your living room
that has a totally artificial portrait
of other people who may be much
wealthier than you and it's broadcasting
in as if you're looking in their window
right in the adjacent house and so you
think you you being triggered to think
that you're doing something wrong that
you might fix when in fact the solution
may not be first of all the person on
the other side of that screen may not be
for real but even if they are they're
not living in the same environment as
you the technology is interfacing with
with our brains badly but so we have
of the perception of massive inequality
economically we do have massive
inequality you're arguing that the
solution to this involves some sort of
massive redistribution but nonetheless
redistribution is wildly unpopular for
various reasons and so what we've got
now is a situation this is speculative
but what's really happening is that
austerity is being used as a threat to
keep people who would otherwise rebel
against the inequality in line and my
fear about this is that this is exactly
the conditions that are going to trigger
that tribal population against
population mayhem that we were talking
about at the beginning of this
conversation that when people have the
sense that the the bursts of growth that
they were experiencing is now over the
natural response is to turn on those who
are not as powerful and take their stuff
that this is a totally indefensible but
nonetheless biological pattern of
history and that if we want to avoid
that we have to stop sending the signals
that trigger us to imagine that we've
just run to the limit of the opportunity
that we had discovered and it is now
time to look and see who can't defend
their positions how are we sending these
signals well by basically failing to
provide enough well-being that people's
perception of the inequality is reduced
to a tolerable level
well the argument for universal basic
income certainly certainly a strong one
and I you know it's also it's also a
good argument for equality of
opportunity right because people are
people are actually not as resentful
about the success of others as you might
expect they're resentful about it if
they feel that the game is fixed mmm but
they're also willing to consider the
game long term so lots of people will
say look like I'm stuck in not zero I'm
stuck at one but my kids might make it
to four and that's good enough and
that's being the American dream right
and that's and that's a really high
power antidote to inequality it's like
well yeah there's some inequality we
need it to keep the generative mechanism
going but the
is fair and you can play it too and
there's some reasonable probability that
either you or someone you love will be
successful so that so it has to be a
straight game and that's why ethics is
so important to keep this landscape
stable people can't play crooked games
and the rich shouldn't be fixing the
game if they want to hold on to their
money and the problem is is that some of
them although not all some of them are
fixing the game and no one's happy about
that and no wonder you know and and I
guess that was evidenced to some degree
by the 2008 collapse because it seemed
and and I'm just as uninformed as the
next person so I'm I'm what I'm capable
of commenting on this it seems from the
outside that the rich disproportionately
benefited from the restabilization of
the economic system and people are not
happy about that and they shouldn't be
happy about that because it indicates
that there's something fundamentally
rotten about the game so you could say
well maybe people can tolerate necessary
inequality if the game isn't raped and
so that's why everybody has to act in a
manner that indicates that the game
isn't rigged and that means they can't
rig it that's really what it means so
and so we're also being driven into this
inequality corner by I would say by the
post modernists and the neo-marxists
because they say this is the pernicious
thing they say well the reason that some
people have more than others is because
every hierarchy is based on arbitrary
power and they're all oppressors and the
reason they have the money is because
they stole it from you and there's some
truth in that because there are some
criminals but when you get to the point
where you fail to distinguish the
productive people from the criminals
which is exactly what happened in the
1920s in the Soviet Union
you better bloody well won't watch out
because when you radically make things
egalitarian you're gonna wipe out all
your productive people and then you're
gonna starve and so that's that's one of
the doomed end scenarios that awaits us
if this idiot process of polarization
continues and what I find reprehensible
about the universities and you're
tangled up right up to your neck in this
is that the universities are actively
agitating to produce people who believe
that all inequality is due to oppression
and power
and that's just well first of all it's
technically wrong but why is that so you
guys both operate in that system so well
here's the problem no as far as I know
nobody has properly studied the question
of what fraction of the economy is
actually crooked rent-seeking right not
productive and I fear that the answer to
that question is that it's an awful
large fraction of the economy not
because of some conspiracy but because
opportunity is finite but con games
aren't and so anybody who can find a
mechanism for transferring wealth from
somebody else for doing nothing finds
that mechanism and that thing is is that
were present whereas discovering the
next big thing that's actually
productive is you know something that
goes along and fits and starts and so if
we were I mean really you've described
it very well we've got a battle between
two caricatures of what's true right
Arthur
either the market is wonderful and it's
producing great stuff with very little
corruption or everything that makes
people unequal is the result of
corruption both of these things are
wrong right markets are marvelous
engines for figuring out how to do
something really well they're brilliant
at this right and so people who see that
fall in love with it understandably
because they're so good at it but what
they're terrible at is telling you what
you should want or what you should do
right if people tell markets here's what
we would like to accomplish and then the
markets tell us well how do we
accomplish that best that would be a
very viable system that would not result
in massive rent-seeking
resulting in everybody feeling that all
of their misfortunes are the result of a
rigged game which is so massively rigged
that when they check they see yes that
is actually a large large to large
extent what we're suffering from but
they want to throw the baby out with the
bathwater and so they want to throw out
markets entirely which you know it would
be a terrible mistake it's a it's a
you asked you why this has happened in
the universities and like that I think
it's one of these runaway positive
feedback processes
you know the universities start to tilt
hard to the left in the 60s and that
just went out of control and now we're
at the point where that's the dominant
force and why is probably another
manifestation of one of these preeto
principles it was like well at some
point there's enough left he's hired so
that the probability that they're only
going to hire people equally as left or
greater starts to reach 100% and then
you iterate that across a couple of
generations and you get no conservatives
which is more or less the situation say
in the humanities and most of the social
sciences and it sort of looks like a
conspiracy but it doesn't mean that
anyone is actually planning it although
there are conscious attempts also to
silence conservative voices let's say
and then that's also driven by this
postmodern ethos no neo-marxist ethos I
would say that says that all of the
right the moral right is on the side of
the left you know and so it's the
combination of those two things there's
more things I think I often often think
comically that if you paid sociology
professors three times as much the
probability that they would be
anti-capitalist would decline
precipitously like I think a lot of it's
driven because there's a lot of smart
people in academia and they're underpaid
relative to their intelligence hmm so
and that doesn't make them happy so they
get bitter and resentful about that and
they think well there's these goddamn
bankers who are hauling in 20 million
dollars a year and Here I am hardly
struggling but here I am struggling
comparatively and that's the issue is
comparatively on a hundred thousand
dollars a year one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a year you know I look
at that and I think well whatever it
doesn't matter but there's a like my
colleagues are often angry with me
because I do work with the business
school you know and I also have a
business are not anti-capitalist in the
least
but I it's just dumbfounding to me
because they'll come up to me and say
well are you so sure that you should be
working with the business school and I
think what bloody planet are you from -
positive question like that's all
businessmen are evil it's like really
that's the level of your sophistication
this is really an argument
that's been presented to you that
businessmen are evil well they don't
come out and say that but they certainly
questioned my motivations for example in
informing ties with the Business School
like what do they say about it they say
exactly that they questioned my ethics
about forming ties with the business
school so many but they don't give you
any reasons your supposed the reason
supposed to be self evident Joe you know
so let's give this argument it's do I
mean I don't buy this argument but but
nonetheless let's let's not let's not
caricature yes that's good in an
absolutely free market which is not what
we have but we have something that tends
in that direction in an absolutely free
market if you compete two individuals
one of whom is completely amoral will
embrace any opportunity if it makes a
profit no matter what it is and the
other individual has some limit to what
they will do well then there's no
question who wins if we give this
experiment long enough period the
individual who will do anything will
out-compete the individual with moral
limits because it's depend on what the
game is though because now you'll find
out that you have no moral limits then
they're going to remove themselves from
your market unfortunately not and no
here's the I know it seems like that and
in any given round that's true okay but
to the extent that what you're saying is
to the extent that people police their
purchasing and they will you know they
will stop using uber if uber is
ethically compromised for example well
then the point is well what's the game
the game is to figure out which things
are being monitored and not do any of
the unethical things that are being
monitored but to do all of the unethical
things that aren't being monitored and
so the individual who is perceiving
which things they can get away with has
an advantage and a Psychopaths advantage
well I don't even want to call it the
psychopath advantage right what this is
is that a market will train you to do
this if it is unregulated and the best
that the ethically that the ethically
restrained person can do is compete dead
even they have no way of getting ahead
because the person that is completely
free the the amoral business actor
has the ability to do anything that the
constrained actor has does this depend
entirely upon what the battlefield is
not really there's there's sort of one
exception and that exception is people
who have done something that has
suddenly put them in a powerful position
right so like tech people write tech
people who have skyrocketed as a result
of having innovated the next big thing
have not been through the markets
training them to discover the the
landscape of what isn't being monitored
that you can make a profit that's one of
the fascinating things about tech people
in general is that these gigantic tech
corporations almost all lean left
well the gigantic tech corporations lean
left that's true on the other hand I
mean I hate to say it but think about
how Google started right don't don't be
evil right I think they actually meant
that right right and the thing is don't
be evil is what it sounds like when you
haven't been trained by the market to
have to do whatever you have to do to
beat your competition you've just come
up with the great search engine and
suddenly you're on top of the world but
over time what happens that entity is
now exposed to competition from a bunch
of other entities that increasingly will
find an advantage in being freer to do
questionable stuff and so what it does
is it forces an entity like Google to
evolve in the direction of a morality so
now don't kind of hang with China Google
yeah Google wanted to expand into China
and so you know they had to make a deal
with the devil so to speak right and
they had accept censorship they will
find ways to rationalize everything
because to not rationalize that which
their competitors can avail themselves
of would be to perish and study issues
was there was all sorts of fake Google
going on just like they have fake Apple
stores in China they don't have the same
sort of copyright laws that we have and
you can essentially plagiarize anything
you want when Brett you you also said
that I shouldn't make a straw man of the
anti business argument of my peers and
there's another way that I shouldn't
make a straw man of it like despite the
fact that I'm not anti-capitalist I
don't believe that every entity
is a business either and one of the
things that has happened to universities
that has actually they pathologized in a
number of dimensions but they've also
pathologized along the business
dimension as the administrators have
become increasingly trained or drawn
from the ranks of business managers
because a university is actually not a
business it's a like a church isn't a
business there are organizations that
aren't businesses that you can't just
cram into the free market structure
willy-nilly and so my colleagues also
object to the to the transformation of
the university into a business entity
run by profit seeking MBAs and they
should object to that because that's not
what the institution is for so there are
reasons for them to be skeptical say of
my association with the business school
that aren't merely a reflection of a
simplistic anti-capitalist ideology oh
there are lots of there are lots of
things that are not they have no
immunity to contact with the market
right what has happened to the
university system is that markets have
pushed it in all kinds of directions
that are not healthy for the mission of
the Academy and this is also true you
know journalism isn't well done in a
market either right journalism done in a
market ends up telling you what you want
to hear not what you need to know
so anyway markets are wonderful but
there's certain things they shouldn't be
allowed to touch and there are certain
things that they shouldn't do like tell
us what to want right they're not
there's no magic principle by which a
market knows what's healthy and what you
know you might crayon that also then
brings us back to another part of the
conservative liberal left dilemma which
is well you know to direct the market
means to impose the heavy hand of the
state and its potential pathologies on
the market but to leave it alone
completely means that it wanders
randomly through through an
indeterminate landscape and and I guess
part of the issue there too is it's sort
of like well how do we how do we how do
we properly balance for foresight and
planning which you'd think would have
some role in in the construction of
large-scale states it's like well what
do we want the landscape to look like
how do we balance that with the sort of
comprehensive computer
that the market allows and of course the
answer to that is we have political
discussions about it all the time that
are untrammeled so that we can adjust
the ratio between those two things as
necessary so again that's a that's a
REIT that's a argument on the side of
free speech yeah I mean you know really
it couldn't be more important the real
answer is that both failures are
frightening right I mean you really
don't want a state nannying you and over
regulating the market and taking the
magic out of it and you don't want the
completely unregulated landscape where
the market you know starts probing the
minds of your children and figuring out
how to sell them things that they don't
have any ability to resist right you
need to figure out what that path is and
it's not easy but you can't do it in a
landscape where you can't talk about the
questions and this brings us the
censorship doesn't it because this is a
real issue with the marketplace of free
ideas when you're talking about whether
it's Google or YouTube or whoever might
be imposing their own morality and their
own ideas on what you should and should
not be able to discuss and what should
and should not be monetized you're
essentially imposing these limits these
look I've read once and it's a very good
point that freedom breeds inequality
because you're free to put as much
effort as you'd like into something and
you're gonna get in equal results and
that if you are truly free in a free
world some people are gonna do far
better than others and just based on
their own input just based on their
effort just based on the the amount of
focus and dedication they have it is
very in equal you know I I know many
people that are far more dedicated than
other people that I know and they do
better
yeah well that's that that's well but
rest by the empirical literature yes
well I mentioned earlier that the two
best predictors of long-term success are
intelligence and conscientiousness and
what intelligence is probably something
like the number of credible operations
that you can manifest in a given period
of time it's something like speed now
it's not only that but it speeds a big
part of it so if what you're doing is
working and you can do it faster that
works better okay that's pretty damn
straightforward and the next thing is
well conscientiousness well
conscientiousness would
be something like how many of those
cycles of effort are devoted to that
specific task and it turns out that if
there's a relationship between the
effort and task success more effort is
better but and so I can give you some
indication of the power of that so if
you have good measures of
conscientiousness and IQ you can predict
someone's success in the competitive
landscape with a correlation of about
0.6 and what that would mean is imagine
that you tried to pick people you just
said randomly you're going to be a
success in the top half of the
successful people say and you're gonna
be in the bottom half you'd have a fifty
four fifty percent chance of do of
making that selection correctly if you
did it randomly if you did it informed
by the results of a good cognitive test
and a conscientious test you'd be right
eighty-five percent of the time so you
can say with 85 percent accurately
accuracy which of two people would be
more likely to be in the top fifty
percent so it's a whopping effect and
it's actually some validation for the
essential integrity of our system
because we hope given that it's
essentially an open meritocracy that
smarter hard-working people would do
better and they do now other factors
apply corruption for example lots of
factors apply I mean for one thing
wrapped up in IQ is a big question which
is how much of the differences in IQ
that exists is democratized law that is
to say how much of this is the result of
environments that aren't enriching or
there's lead in the water or who knows
what not enough vitamins right my my
sense actually my intuition based on
what I know biologically is that a huge
fraction maybe all of it but a huge
fraction of differences in IQ is
actually could be generalized and that's
part of equal opportunity it's not an
easy opportunity Tessa mystic about that
and that's partly because I mean maybe
because I spent a lot of because I'm
interested in the amelioration of
differences you know so for example
that's why I built this future authoring
program it's like hey if we can figure
out how to make people more effective
well let's do it so I scoured the
literature on on IQ enhancement and it's
bloody dismal man when it's rough it's
very very difficult to put two
a cognitive training program like some
things have worked in a major way like
the fact that people aren't starving has
wiped out has moved the bottom of the IQ
distribution way up over the last
hundred years that's been like a
walloping success but a lot of the
things that we hoped would work like
head starts a good example of that
you know Head Start was part of the
American war on poverty and the idea was
you'd give you know deprived deprived
kids leg up early before they hit school
and start training them cognitively
earlier and the hope was that you'd get
a pre dough thing going where they'd be
a little smarter in kindergarten and
then they'd do a little better in grade
one and that would make them do even
more better in grade two more better do
better than grade two but what happened
what happened was that the kids who went
through Head Start actually did get a
cognitive jump on their competitors but
all the other kids caught up by grade
six and by grade six there was
absolutely no effect whatsoever of the
training program left now Head Start did
have a couple of benefits one was fewer
teenage pregnancies and fewer dropouts
but that was probably because the kids
who got into Head Start were either
socialized better or that some fraction
of them were removed from for some time
from extremely toxic environments just
well they happen to be at headstart
but it didn't produce the cognitive
improvements that everyone right and
left were equally hoping for yeah but
this is this is in some sense it's a
very much an uncontrolled experiment
right because a head start starts late
yep and B it doesn't insulate you from
all of the stuff that comes along with
oh yeah yeah growing up in in the
deprived neighborhood and so absolutely
now also I really don't know what the
truth is of of human IQ and there there
are some results that suggest some
things that are not hopeful on the other
hand some of them just simply run afoul
with
the biological realities of intelligence
well here's a good example of of the
lack of malleability I mean there's a
couple of things the first is that we
may have already we may already be at a
point of diminishing returns in terms of
eliminating individual differences in IQ
because everyone has central heating
everyone has air-conditioning everyone
has enough food everyone has access to
the an infinite pool of information so
you can say even if you're in a deprived
environment but you're smart though
intellectual landscape is wide open to
you now I'm not saying that's the case
but you can make a case for that but the
more dismal end of the of the biological
research and IQ shows things like if you
take identical twins at birth and you
put them in adopted out families that
the IQ of the adopted out twins is much
clearer there it's much closer aid to
the original biological parents than to
the adoptive parents and be almost
perfectly correlated with one another
and that correlation increases as the
separated twins age so let's say you had
a twin you were both adopted out at
Birth we test your IQs at four they're
fairly close they're closer to your
biological parents than your adoptive
parents but then we test you every year
until you're 60 by the time you're sixty
no matter how long you've been separated
as as a identical twin your IQ score is
so much like you're twins IQ score that
it's as if the same person was being
tested twice and that's a really
complicated one because you think well
as twins travel through the environment
and accrue different experiences their
IQs should diverge like obviously that's
not what happens well so there are a lot
of places to critique that for one thing
there aren't very many identical twins
raised apart it's a small sample this is
definitely true those identical twins
raised apart carry with them whatever
effects there were from before they were
born for sure the same and so if they
you know if they've been damaged by an
environment that was unhealthy for their
when she was pregnant then they would
carry that through and it would show up
as as a similar IQ later in life so that
one really wants to see that this is
true on the positive side not just the
negative side so anyway there's I'm not
saying that there's nothing to it I'm
really saying I think we don't know it's
very early in this but what I can say
and I think you know a couple of the
things that we've settled on in this
conversation already are that a an
environment in which we can say anything
that we can advance any argument and
test it it doesn't mean that that
argument is protected but that any
argument can be advanced and then
challenged that that is inherent to
navigating and the other thing that I
think we would agree on is that equality
of opportunity is nothing but good right
a fair game with equality of opportunity
fair game with equality of opportunity
and I guess one thing I would add I
don't know if we would agree on this but
you were talking about the fact that
forget which thing exactly but but that
a system based on merit produces
inequality because people will freedom
yeah that freedom produces inequality
that's not necessarily a bad thing but
it doesn't mean that we are obligated to
ride it all the way down right the fact
is we could make people safe to fail
right so that you are encouraged to
attempt to do something highly valuable
and if you if it doesn't work out then
the point is you're not homeless this
would be the the argument for something
like universal basic income
thank you your needs are taking care of
your food your shelter and now you're
free to pursue any ideas that you might
have that you would ordinarily be
saddled down by your issues with food
and well there there are some evidence
of that actually happening yeah I'm in
Canada now these are multi variable
problems and so I'm not claiming that
this is true but it's suggestive the
rate of entrepreneurial activity in
Canada is actually higher than in the
United States and one reason for that
appears to be the fact that if you're
2527 let's say and you have a family you
can quit your job and start a startup
and you don't lose your health care mmm
right and so now
you know the issue of universal
healthcare is obviously a very thorny
one and it's not like the Canadian
system works perfectly but it doesn't
work too badly and we've been able to
manage it for about 50 years you know we
have there's there's artificial scarcity
in the system and the delay times are
longer than they would be if you flew to
the Mayo Clinic and bought your health
care like I would say that at the high
end the American healthcare system is
better than the Canadian healthcare
system but I would say at the middle and
at the low end the Canadian healthcare
system is clearly preferable and it's
also cheaper which is quite interesting
because you would expect especially if
you're a free-market type that you know
I know the healthcare system in the u.s.
is not precisely free-market but it is
more so than it is in Canada yet
Americans pay a substantially higher
proportion of their overall devote a
higher proportion of their overall GDP
to personal health care the Canadians do
and and the stats are similar if you
look at other you know quasi socialized
medical there's a great piece on that by
Adam ruins everything have you ever seen
that television show it's really
interesting he breaks down pretty much a
lot of different subjects but Bakke
breaks down the American healthcare
system to pretty much where it went
wrong and I just encourage anybody to go
watch it because it just shows how they
elevated the price of all sorts of
different things just sort of make up
for you know a lack of profits and it's
really it's a really fascinating little
piece we are already almost three hours
into this so we haven't talked about
Hitler oh we kind of we kind of did it
kind of have but let me just do you want
to lay out your argument about Hitler
and then I'll respond to it and I don't
know if I do want to I mean I think I
actually think that I should stop
because I'm kind of at the limits of I'm
at the point where the probability that
I will say something stupid is starting
to increase and I would rather not
because just saying the things that I'm
trying to say that aren't stupid is
dangerous enough yes this isn't the
topic where you want to make that
connection yes boy is there a more
charged subject it's funny that it's
charged because as you point out we're
pretty much all in agreement about it
right
I mean you find someone who's not and
they're instantly ostracized from
society right anybody who has an
argument about Genghis Khan I mean
there's a really fascinating take on
this by Dan Carlin from hardcore history
he's talking about the amount of time
that has passed since a horrible
atrocity and that there are people that
will argue that Genghis Khan who killed
10 percent of the world's population
changed things so badly that it
literally lowered the carbon footprint
of the human race while he was alive
killed some untold number of millions of
people and was responsible for their
deaths people look to him and they find
all sorts of positive things to
attribute to his reign opening up trade
with China opening up trade routes
although all these different things that
people have attributed to him and that
someday someone may do the same thing
about Adolf Hitler right now well it's
impossible he he certainly made that job
very difficult with all of the
documentation yes especially the films
but but let's just say the argument that
I want to level I want to be really
careful to do this so that it can't be
misinterpreted by anybody I'm gonna
enjoy watching this if I'm cornered okay
so my argument from all those years ago
in my my paper that I was did for Bob
Trivers that I mentioned at the
beginning was that Hitler was a monster
as we all know but he was a rational
monster that the program that he
deployed was not what he said mind you
what he said was wrong in many places
especially where it gets near Darwinism
it's just all tangled and broken but
what he did was rational from the point
of view of increasing the amount of
resource that was dedicated to producing
members of his population and so my
point is this is the danger that we are
in if we allow ourselves to imagine
and that Jenna Seidel impulses are more
or less gone from the world because
we've all assumed we've all agree that
they're a bad thing and the point is
that they exist in a latent program and
at a point when you have austerity as a
result of usually a an opportunity that
has run its course and has resulted in
the population growing to fill that
opportunity and suddenly there's nowhere
to go because the opportunity has all
been absorbed the tendency of people is
to figure out who what other population
is weak and if that population is across
a border then there's some excuse for
war and if the population is within the
border then it's a genocide but the
point is that is an ever-present danger
for us okay so I want to clarify one
thing I'm sure because this argument was
sort of phrased as we have a
disagreement about Hitler and I would
like to point out that I don't actually
disagree with anything that you just
said okay if I remain relatively silent
I don't want to be seen I don't want it
to be seen that the fact that I'm
disagreeing with you means or that there
is a disagreement means that it's a
disagreement about any of that
I think the disagreement was something
like I said that Hitler was even more
evil than we thought he was and you I
think correct me if I'm wrong you're
pointing out the danger of assuming that
you can put Hitler in a he was just a
monster box and don't think about it
anymore and I would say I agree
absolutely with that I mean
I've studied Hitler a lot and there's a
bunch of things that you can't say about
him you can't say he was stupid right
you can't say he was without artistic
talent you can't say that he was a poor
organizer you can't say that he wasn't
charismatic you can't say that he did
wonders freako Germany's economy in the
first part of his reign and and and so
it's very necessary when you're if
you're dealing intelligently with a true
monster that you give the devil his due
yeah so I think the thing that I saw in
your video was your argument was that as
he was losing instead of
putting the genocide on pause and
winning and winning the warning that
hehe ratcheted it up the jam yeah I
don't know if it would really be I don't
think it's necessarily fair to say that
it was him that did that although I
think he had a hand in it it does appear
to me that that's what happened right
and my point would simply be and again
there
I couldn't possibly be less sympathetic
with the individual my point is simply
that from an evolutionary point of view
if your objective is coldly to increase
the number of genomes that are spelled
the same way that yours are on earth
that a he did enslave those Jews who
were most fit to work in service of the
German war machine right that's what
those camps are not all of the camps
were work camps but you know ouch wits
for example was both a work camp and a
death camp and so there was this
tendency to enslave and so let me ask
you a question if you have this because
you know I think you have to make a
pretty tenuous biological argument to
say that there's evolutionary utility in
increasing the number of your kinsmen
but unless they're very close but but
here's a slight variation of that you
tell me what you think about this is it
reasonable to presume that a decent
survival strategy is to homogenize your
environment with regards to under some
conditions to homogenizer your
environment with regards to racial or
ethnic differences to decrease the
probability that you and yours are going
to be killed oh yeah again no defense of
this yes you are right that okay extent
that there's another population that's
distinct that that population even if it
is small and as little power now might
not be small and have little power later
and so undoubtedly that program is there
- okay okay but I would say that the the
tendency to believe that evolution only
functions at the level of kin when
you're talking about
very close relatives I believe is an
error that only the result of the fact
that evolutionists early on wished to
operationalize fitness and it's very
hard to operationalize Fitness across
population level DIF
and so they built a definition that is
about immediate kin but there's no
logical reason to imagine that that
Peters out at the edge okay so okay so
all I'm arguing is that what Hitler did
was go after a population inside his
border that was more distantly related
to the people who were his constituents
and then he went obviously after Eastern
Europe and sought the future of Germany
in Russia and it took 12 million
Russians to turn around the German war
machine I mean those are military deaths
there were vastly more civilian deaths
but but the point is he did not succeed
in doing what he set out to do but he
also didn't fail in the sense that he
took a bunch of resources that belonged
to a population that was more distantly
related and he got rid of those people
and by getting rid of them increased the
amount of resource that was available to
Aryans this has nothing to do genes are
not interested in figuring out which
genes are superior all of the language
about German superiority is nonsense
however genes are very interested I mean
they're obviously genes they don't think
but they act as if they are interested
in replacing alternative spellings okay
and so part of the reason that you're
walking through this just so that this
the track of this remains self-evident
is to caution people against to alert
people to the fact that the sorts of
programs that Hitler both ran and
elicited from people are lurking in our
let's say in our genome in our in our
set of biological possibilities and we
have to be very awake to that fact on an
ongoing basis they are lurking in our
genomes which does not mean that we as
adults have this as a possibility many
people will not go along with this other
people have it lurking to be triggered
and I think you know what worries me is
that Trump I think very cynically
utilized this lurking program in order
to to gain office that he played upon
the fact that certain people were
to hear those noises and what he said
about Charlottesville you know again he
did not he did not go after the white
nationalists the way did you see the
white nationalist response do you see
those
yeah the Daler storm had is that what
it's called I think what one of the one
of the white nationalist papers had a
breakdown of what Trump did and that
essentially at the end they were saying
he didn't go after us he didn't target
us this was very good he was very clear
that it was all sides and that he never
once targeted us didn't say anything bad
about us
senator then they said god bless Trump
at the end of it there's a real tricky
issue there about truth you know because
I was because my free speech the free
speech panel that I was a part of was
cancelled I had to make comments in the
Canadian media about Charlottesville and
so I really had to think about what
Trump said because the the fact that
there is reprehensible behavior on both
sides of the extremes of the
distribution is true however truth is a
tricky thing because you have to take
the temporal context into account you
know because I would say you can imagine
that there are white lies and black
truths a black truth is when you use the
truth in a way that isn't truthful just
like a white lie is when you use when
you lie in a way that isn't harmful you
can use the truth to wound and hurt and
what that really means is that you've
misused the truth and so it's actually a
complex form of lie but what what what
Trump did wrong this is independent of
whether or not he was actually engaging
in manipulation or deceit was he failed
to specify the time and the place for
the utterance because what he should
have come out and done was said I
unequivocally denounce the white
supremacist racism that emerged in
Charlottesville yes and then he should
have shut up and then two weeks later he
could have said well would we look at
the political landscape as a whole
perhaps commenting on Berkeley he could
have said it's pretty obvious that there
are reprehensible individuals acting out
at both ends of the extreme but the
Charlottesville week wasn't the week to
make that point so and you know
what why he did that well it could be
just ineptness because it was a very
tricky week to exactly get things right
I don't think so I think actually we can
look at the what he did during the
election and I think we should expect
that he would do exactly what he did
well fair enough that I think there's
there's a wink and a nod to them always
with neo-nazis and whites president Pau
Donald Trump's response at daily yeah
see see if he could see the actual does
it show the actual text of what they
were wrote because quote from the editor
here right there I use didn't mention
anything to do with us reporters were
screaming at him in the white
nationalism he just walked out of the
room huh right there's there was an
actual article that they wrote on one of
those websites Trump's comments were
good he didn't attack that's it didn't
attack us just said the nation should
come together nothing specific against
us he said that we need to study why
people get so angry and implied that
there was hate dot on both sides
exclamation point so he implied that the
antiva are haters mm-hmm I mean so that
energized them in a way and there's no
secret that they support him you know my
friend Alonzo Bodden is a very funny
quote he's a comedian he goes not all
Trump supporters are racist but all
racists are traitors it's a it's a great
quote and he that's there's political
power in that whether or not Trump is a
racist or whether it's the wink and the
nod to that side that is the only weaken
the nod that they're getting I mean yeah
or even or even insufficient
denunciation which was kind of what did
and there's a Canadian journalist named
faith Goldie who got fired from rebel
media for being being accused of being
too cozy with daily stormer type she did
a podcast with with crypto and I
listened to the podcast very carefully
she was actually one of the people that
was supposed to be a panelist on this
free speech talk so that put us in a
real bind but well what happened in the
podcast well what happened was in my
estimation was that she didn't properly
fulfill her role as critical journalists
she was it was sort of like a discussion
with your friendly neighbor
neo-nazi and what I mean by that is she
didn't ally herself
la la hers Alai herself with any of the
purported aims of the neo-nazi people
she was talking to but I think she
failed to criticize them sufficiently
she didn't ask the tough questions you
know now and and that and that that was
a that was well it was a fatal error I
mean she got fired from rebel media and
and it's gonna have terrible
repercussions for her although she may
land on her feet but rebel media is very
conservative as well right certainly by
Canadian stand yes yeah yeah that's
right no rebel media did like imploded
in the aftermath of Charlottesville
because of what faith Goldie did with
with the daily it wasn't even the daily
stormer it was a group called crypto but
they're they're associated with the
daily stormer so she went on there which
I think you could make you could make a
case that that's okay as a journalist
you can go talk to neo-nazis but the
question is how do you talk to them and
the answer to that is you point out
their agenda
you don't allow them to masquerade as
friendly as friendly innocent people you
can't do that and so I would say she
danced she dammed herself by
insufficiently criticizing the villains
it was something like that
you uh familiar you I'm sure you are
familiar with Louie through no I'm not
every through the documentary and II
know him from England fascinating guy
fantastic like one of the best and one
of the things that he's done is well
he's interviewed a ton of different
people but one of the great ones that he
did was the Westboro Baptist Church and
he sort of embedded himself with them
and was very congenial and very like
kind and unthreatening and stayed with
them for long periods of time like weeks
on end and got them to eventually like
expose who they were and and understand
from like the point of view of an
insider and in a sense without
necessarily condemning them but with
just constantly asking questions but
being very very polite about it not like
a bunch
not like a lot of serious like
confrontational criticism rather but a
very friendly sort of polite British way
of discussing thing and he's
particularly good at embedding himself
he did it with Scientology he's done it
with a bunch of different groups he
embeds himself and just sort right so
there's so there's a justification for
attempting that sort of thing clearance
yes but and I really had to think this
through because well what happened with
our talk was it was so Hall of Mirrors
like it was like it was a talk about
free speech talks being shut down on
campus that was shut down by a campus
and it was a panel of people who purport
to support free speech who knocked
someone off the panel because of
something well not precisely that she
said but it's close enough to make right
irony rather palpable it is so I I had
to go through what happened with faith
very carefully to figure out what the
right ethical pathway was you know but I
listened to the podcast very carefully I
listened to with my son and we talked
about a lot and our conclusion was that
she had failed - she had failed - she
didn't ask enough tough questions one
would have done it even maybe - would
have done it for sure but it was that
the discussion was too cordial hmm and
it could have even been cordial to your
point because maybe that would have led
to more discussions yeah but it should
have been cordial with one snake bite
you know that was not required to make
that snake bite I mean well depends what
you mean by required well but my thought
is like to find out what these people
really want and really like we're really
trying to achieve sometimes you don't
have to be confrontational with them you
just gotta allow them to be comfortable
look and kamau Bell did that really
great on a CNN show with the KKK he sort
of just allowed them to be themselves
and they became more and more
comfortable with him the more time they
spent with him to the point where
they're actually joking around with him
but you got to see that the ugliness was
so obvious and evident and without him
confronting them on it without him
yelling and arguing you got to see it
from him just being friendly and joking
around with them now nobody would ever
accuse a black man like kamau Bell
with being
a sympathizer with the KKK he was in
this inarguable position like no one no
one could accuse him of it this woman
I'm assuming is white that's where the
problem lies what if she was problems
yeah she was a black woman in the very
same situation like Oprah was in the
past like Oprah interviewed the KKK in
the past and she was never accused of
being like somehow or another a
sympathetic person to them right and
somehow we we have to raise the
threshold of offense there's there are
lots of ways to contribute to the
conversation one of them may be to embed
yourself and actually allow the world to
see yes people who are doing something
abhorrent in the in the way that they
see themselves so you can understand it
right being there asking questions right
you don't necessarily have to be cute
what are you to change them I'm being
critical to them I mean just getting in
arguments with them I mean they might be
able to see something from that from
their response to like rational
discussion about their issues
this brings us down a whole other rabbit
hole which maybe we could talk about at
some point in the future because this is
a really interesting topic you know like
part of the reason that I've been
accused of being on the far-right say or
on the alt-right is because I've talked
to people talk with people who perhaps
have are closer
what would you say have an association
network that might be more closely
allied with that than people are
comfortable with but my attitude has
been to it's and and I don't want to
talk about this in much detail because
it's really complicated but the the anti
left spectrum let's say is very confused
and it could easily tilt very rapidly
into the hard right anti left which is
the danger that that you are describing
and partly what I'm hoping is that I can
talk to people who might conceivably be
on that developmental pathway because
they're they're tired of being accused
of implicit racism let's say and say
look you can be anti radical left
without falling all the way into the to
the far right and here's how you might
do it but that means I have to talk to
them and then if I talk to them that
means I risk association with them and
that risks being tainted it's a very
tricky line to walk well it's also one
of the
one of the big problems with this hard
stance of the of the left of the hard
left like this Pepe the Frog thing like
that anybody I mean one of the things
that I tweeted was some guy that called
me you just admitted you're a Nazi
because you I posted a meme that someone
had created of me as Pepe the Frog that
apparently these Pepe the Frog of
everybody and so I put this guy was like
well you just admitted you're a Nazi and
I'm like see this is a part of the
problem and this creates a massive
blowback people getting angry because
that frog for the most part is used
humorously and yeah actually you use the
phrase defensive humor yeah and it
really is and I think I mean this is I
didn't mean to interrupt your joke but
no please there's there's something
about the idea that the effectiveness of
this meme is that it tangles people with
no sense of humor in knots and that's a
huge part of why those things are
generated that's why it's nicely that's
exactly right yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm
fearing that I'm saying something about
this frog and that there's gonna be
something that's gonna emerge that I
should know about that somehow I'm
admitting something but all I'm saying
is what I see is a lot of people using
it to taunt people yes can't figure out
I think that's the vast majority of it I
do believe that and I think the same
thing about the keka Stanny types is
that that's almost all humour yeah and
there's some massive problem with
pushing back against that and calling
those people Nazis and racists and
especially when they're just using humor
and especially when it's very clear if
you look at all the memes online and I
went thoroughly through Google to find
them there are some abhorrent ones there
are some horrible ones there are some
ones that are with Nazi uniforms there's
some some anti Jew ones there's some
horrific ones most of them are not that
most of them the vast majority of them
are humorous and if and again these
people are not coordinating so if one
person decides to make a Mickey Mouse
racist meme which by the way a lot of
the early Mickey Mouse cartoons you
could just take a screenshot and they're
[ __ ] tremendously racist right
because dealing with the side of the
times I mean images of black people that
work extremely cartoonish you know giant
lid
black faces the whole deal or a horribly
racist you could say Mickey Mouse's
[ __ ] racist don't go to Disneyland no
one's saying that right but they could
and this is a slippery slope
you start with the Frog you know and you
know first they came for Pepe and I
didn't say any yeah well if the Frog is
racist you start entering what isn't
racist cartoon frog but you can make
some cartoon about everything that has
ever existed and make that racist it
doesn't mean that the Frog is racist
this is where it's crazy it's like what
percentage of people are making the Frog
racist and then for the Southern Poverty
Law Center to say that this is a symbol
of hate now this frog well well guess
what you just back these [ __ ] people
up against the wall and you sure their
offense is because now they're realizing
oh well these people are mad they're
they're crate not just mad like angry
but mad like insane like you're not
looking at this thing rationally at all
you're saying that a frog where 99% of
the memes or just humorous or silly now
the Frog is a hate symbol not only a
hate symbol but Nazi know a supremacist
I mean you're they're just drying up all
of the space between their preposterous
perspective and the nightmare at the
other end of the spectrum and the point
is almost all of us live in that
intermediate space so yeah it's almost
all thoughts live in that intermediate
space right there's a variability of all
thoughts you know there's there's
flexibility of all ideas and when you're
talking about something with it words
extremely humorous you're talking about
a humorous frog I mean goddamn need to
call that all hate when sometimes it's
hate and some by who by what are the
[ __ ] people are that did that hateful
thing those are the people that are
hateful not the other ones that are
using that frog for humor I mean this is
the fact that this is an argument at all
just shows how lost we are in these
ideological arguments is left versus
right extreme end of the spectrum on one
end of the field throwing rocks at the
far end of the field
yeah it's most of us are in the middle
somewhere it's hopeless yeah if we
cannot have discussions a lot of nog
I mean Jesus Christ well that's a nice
conclusion yeah it might be it might be
listen this was a lot of fun as always
in right and I'm glad you guys came up
with this idea and I'm glad we had the
time to do it yeah Jordan Peterson what
is your Twitter handle again Jordan
Pederson yep and Brett weinstein right
weinstein on twitter once tied up at
saying weinstein it doesn't make you're
not interchangeable
sorry sorta sorta alright but thank you
guys really appreciate it a lot of fun
yep goodnight again bye everybody
[Music]